THE COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
FUN ACTIVITY IN THE CAPITAL
TODAY WE WITH A NINETY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS WHICH
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PAY
OUR- ELECTRIC BILL BUT- WE'LL
SEE WHAT'S- RIGHT THERE THAT'S
GOOD STUFF. I TRY I TRY MY BEST
NOT TO THAT WAS BETTER THAN
THEIR THEIR JOB. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. WITH WITH THE BIPARTISAN
APPROVAL OF MY SENSE OF HUMOR-
WELL YOU DIDN'T PUT. ANY INPUT
INTO EXACTLY. MY WIFE WITH SAY
PEOPLE ONLY LAUGHED BECAUSE I'M
THE CHAIR THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NO WE HAVEN'T DONE
ANYTHING YET WE'RE ALL GOOD FOR
JUST IN THE BETTER MODE OKAY ALL
RIGHT- WARM UP YOUR IN THE WARM
UP SO GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AS
WE CONTINUE TO TAKE PRECAUTIONS
TO MANAGE THE ON GOING CODE
NINETEEN REST THE SENATE
WELCOMES THE PUBLIC TO OUR
PROCEEDINGS. TODAY WERE HOLDING
OUR SUSPENSE FILE HEARING HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OF
THE- STREET BUILDING. PROSELYTE
STREAMING HEARING COMMEMORATIVE
THE PUBLIC MEMBERS AND MEMBERS
AND STAFF A FOLLOW ALONG FROM A
DISTANCE. AS A REMINDER TO
EVERYONE OUT THERE TODAY'S
HEARING CONSISTS ONLY OF ITEMS
THAT ARE ON THE SUSPENSE FILE.
ALL THESE MID MEASURES HAVE
ALREADY HAD A HEARING. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE WILL COME
UP TO ME ALL THE TIME AND SAY
WELL WHY DON'T YOU HEALTHY
HEARING. WHEN WE DO THE
SUSPENSEFUL BECAUSE WE WERE HAD
IT THAT EVERYONE HAS HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO OFFER PUBLIC
TEST DURING THOSE HEARINGS. AS
NOTED IN DAILY FILE THE SUSPENSE
WHILE HEARING IS A VOTE ONLY.
WITH NO TESTIMONY. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE FOLLOW. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THEIR STAFF. MY STAFF-
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR ASSISTANCE
AND WORK ON THESE IMPORTANT
MEASURES THROUGHOUT. OUR
LEGISLATIVE YEAR SO FAR. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK ONE OF THE CONSULTANTS TO
THE COMMITTEE. SAMANTHA LOUIS
FOR HER YEARS OF SERVICE TO THE
SENATE. AS THIS IS HER FINAL
HEARING WITH APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BEFORE SHE DEPARTS FOR
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY SHE WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED. AND WE- ENJOY CHICKEN.
NOTED INSIDE COMMITTEE JOKES
ASSEMBLE APPRECIATE THAT THAT
SHE WILL DEFINITELY BE MISSED
THE GOOD NEWS IS SHE'S MOVING TO
MY DISTRICT. SO I LOSER AS A
STAFF MEMBER FOR A GAME OR AS A
BOSS- I'D ALSO LIKE TO GIVE US.
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO OUR VICE
CHAIR SENATOR BATES AND HER
FISCAL STAFF FOR THEIR
COOPERATION AND COLLABORATION
THROUGH. THIS VERY INTERESTING
YEAR. BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE
TO MAKE A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS OF
HOW WE'LL PROCEED SO THAT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MEMBERS
AND STAFF CAN FOLLOW ALONG. WILL
BE MOVING QUICKLY THROUGH THE
AGENDA ALPHABETICALLY IN AUTHOR
ORDER. PLAY CLOSE ATTENTION AS
WILL ONLY BE ADDRESSING MEASURES
THAT WILL BE UP FOR A VOTE THIS
MORNING IF YOU DON'T HEAR ME
TAKE UP A PARTICULAR MEASURE.
THAT BILL IS HELD UNDER
SUBMISSION. I'LL ANNOUNCE THE
AUTHOR MEASURE NUMBER AND
PROVIDE A BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF
ANY AMENDMENTS. TO THE MEASURE
BEFORE WE TAKE THE VOTE.
FOLLOWING THE HEARING WILL BE
POSTING THE HEARING RESULTS AND
THE ACTIONS TAKEN ON EACH
MEASURE ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AT W. W. W. DOT S. A. P. R.
SENATE. C. A. DOT GOV THAT IS W.
W. DOT. S. A. P. R. DOT. DOT IT
. FOR ANY BILLS ARE BEING. TODAY
WILL BE HOST WE WILL BE HOSTING
AN ADDENDUM ANALYSIS WHICH
INCLUDES A SUMMARY OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND THE REVISED
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THOSE AMENDED
BILL SO LOOK OUT FOR THAT. SO
NOW WILL GO AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM IN FACT NOW IS THE TIME
TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER PORTANTINO. I'M HERE
PORTANTINO HERE CENTER BATES.
BATES HERE SENATOR BRADFORD YOUR
BRADFORD HERE SENATOR JONES.
JONES HERE SENATOR KAMLAGER HERE
KAMLAGER HERE CENTER LAYERED
HERE LATER HERE CENTER
MACASKILL. CASKEY HERE OF SEVEN
MEMBERS. WE HAVE SENATE MEMBERS
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE GONNA
GO RIGHT TO OUR AGENDA. AND SO
OUR FIRST BILL UP ARE UNDER.
SENATOR ALAN S. B. TEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SEA LEVEL RISE REVOLVING
LOANS THIS IS A DO PASS WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO BROADEN
THE DEFINITION OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES. IT IS WE
DON'T NEED A MOTION RIGHT HERE
WE DO NEED A MOTION- NOBODY IN
IT I DON'T THINK SO I THINK WE
WERE JUST CHECKING THE VOTE TOOK
A ROLL CALL OKAY SO THE MOST
THAT IS THE MOTION AND THAT IS A
RECOMMENDATION FOR ITS AUTHORS
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE. EIGHT SB
TEN SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES
NOBODY. IT'S NOT LOADING
BRADFORD. OUR BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. JONES NO CENTER
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I CENTER
LAYER BY LAYER I CENTER RECOUNTS
SKI HI MAKOWSKI BY. IT IS FIVE
TWO ONE FIVE TO ONE THAT BILL
MOVES TO THE SENATE FLOOR MOVING
ON THE SENATE BILL S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR ALAN THANK
EBERLE A AND LOWER LOS ANGELES
RIVER AND MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
WHICH IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO. THE SENATE
FLOOR AND THAT IS THE MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
CENTER BATES BATES AYE SENATOR
BRADFORD BRADFORD BY SENATOR
JONES HI JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER
HI KAMLAGER ICE CENTER LAYERED
HI EARLIER I CENTER MY COUNTY HI
MY COUNTY ARE. SEVEN ZERO SO
THAT BILL IS OUT SEVENTIES IRWIN
THAT ESTABLISHED OUR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL SO WHEN I DO A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE.
THE EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO AYE FORTINO AYE BATES
. SENATE BRADFORD. BRADFORD ICE
UNDERGROUND JONES JONES I CENTER
KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER I SENATOR
LAYER ON LAYER BY SENATOR MIKE
OSCAR I KELSEY I THAT. SIX TWO
ZERO. THAT BILLS OUT SIX ZERO.
MOVING ON TO SENATE BILL TWELVE
OH FIVE ON WATER RIGHTS IT IS A
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATE BILL
TWELVE OH FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES
FIVE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JONES
JONES BY KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER
LAYERED ON LAYERED BY CASKEY HI
OKAY- SEVEN ZERO. THAT BILL IS
OUT IS A- WE WILL AS TWELVE
SEVENTEEN I CALL CLIMATE IN
EQUITY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT'S MOTION. SENATE BILL
TWELVE SEVENTEEN MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
CENTER BATES. HEALTH BREAK BATES
NO CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES JONES KNOWS CENTER
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I SENATOR
LAYERED ALL RIGHT LAYERED I SAID
ACCOUNTS HI LIKE ASK HI THAT
BODES FIVE TO TWO. THAT LOTUS
FIVE TO TWO WE JUST ESTABLISH
OUR BEER CALL WHEN I ACCEPT. FOR
THE ROLE FROM A B. TWO SEVENTY
YOUNG THOUGH THAT THOSE ARE FIVE
TO VOTE. ALL RIGHT FORWARD SO
NOW WE'LL GO TO ASK TWELVE EIGHT
I'M CLEAN. PROGRAM FLEET
OPERATED. IT IS A ROLL CALL WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT SO THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO EXCUSE ME THAT I
HAD AMENDMENTS- I'M SORRY
AMENDS- AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
ADD A CO AUTHOR SO WHAT THE
MOTION IS. TO MOVE TO THE FLOOR
WITH AUTHORS A MEMBER SAID CO
AUTHORS AND SO THAT IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO RECEPTION IN THE ROLE FROM
SB ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. WILL BE ON
S. B. TWELVE NINETY ON STREET
VENDORS. IT IS A DO PASS. AND
WE'RE GONNA ROLL CALL ON THIS
ONE. SO THAT'S THE MOTION.
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR.
CENTER PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE SENATOR BATES. BATES AYE
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD BY
SENATOR JONES. JONES KNOWS
CENTER KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER ICE
AND EARLIER. LAYER I SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE E. AYE CASKEY BY SIX
TO ONE. THAT FILLS OUT SIXTY ONE
MOVING ON SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BUILDING STANDARDS ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT IS GOT AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
ADD CO AUTHORS. AND SO WE ARE
GOING TO LET THAT OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL SO WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTEEN. SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT- I
MISSED THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO BUT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WE JUST DID
ON A B. ROLL CALL. I'M GONNA GO
BACK TO SB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO.
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR RUN REPORT.
REPORTING CONTRIBUTIONS AND IT'S
A ROLL CALL VOTE TO MOVE IT TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES NOT VOTING
CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD BY
SENATOR JONES. JONES KNOWS
SENATOR KAMLAGER HI. KAMLAGER HI
CENTER LAYER ON. LAYER I SENATOR
MICHALSKI I. CASKEY VOTERS FIVE
TO ONE THAT DOES OUT FIVE TO
ONE. AND MARK YOU WANNA. CLARIFY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO OR WE COULD
- JUST FOR WHERE THERE MAY ON
THE ONE FOR I DO IS A TO CO
AUTHOR PERFECT JUST THAT WAS A
IS OUT ON A B. ROAD CALL. FIVE
TWO. THANK MOVING TO SENATOR
ARCH ALETTA SB NINE FIFTY
CALFRESH BASIC ALLOWANCE FOR
OUT WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
OF S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
SB NINE FIFTY I WAS OUT. SEVEN
ZERO SB NINE FIFTY FOUR PUBLIC
WORKS WAGES ELECTRONICS
CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORDS. THAT
IS A VIEW ROLL CALL WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN. SB NINE FIFTY
FOUR SO THAT IS OUT. FIVE TWO
TWO. SB NINE EIGHTY FOR MILITARY
SERVICE LEAVE OF ABSENCE PAY AND
BENEFITS. THAT IS IN A ROLL CALL
SO WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM S. ELEVEN TWENTY TO. BREAST
FEED NINE EIGHTY FOUR SO THAT IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. SB TEN
SEVENTY SIX LEAD BASED PAINT.
THAT IS A ROLL CALL MOTION TO
MOVE IT TO THE FLOOR AS IT
TRACKS SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO
HI. PORTANTINO AYE SAID BATES
NOBODY. NOT DOING CENTER BROWARD
. EFFORT I SENATOR JONES JONES
KNOWS CAMPUS I AM LONG I CENTER
. LAYER I SENT A REQUEST HI
BECAUSE KIANA VOTES FIVE TWO A
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ONE MOVING
SB TO FOUR NAY. MAINLY MANGANESE
MAY MANGANESE DRINKING STANDARD
IT HAS AUTHOR. AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHORED A PER MORE TO PAY THE
HEALTH. AND WE'RE GONNA DO A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THIS BILL AS
AMENDED PER AUTHOR SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES AYE.
BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES JONES
KNOWS CENTER KAMLAGER. HI
KAMLAGER I SENATOR LAYERED
LAYERED I SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
MAKOWSKI HI BOTH A SIX TO ONE IF
IT WAS OUT SIXTY ONE MOVING ON
SP THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN PROPERTY
TAXATION EXEMPTION DISABLED
VETERANS HOMEOWNERS. IT IS SAID
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL SERVER
SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE FROM S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. FOR SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN SO THAT
BILLS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO SB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE. IT
FINANCES. THIS IS A DO PASSED
WITH THE- TO MAKES E. C.
REQUIREMENTS CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. AND SO IT'S A
ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES NOPE BATES NOTES
CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES JONES NO SENATOR
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER EYES CENTER
LAYER ON LAYER BY SENATOR
MURKOWSKI HI KANSKE R. VOTERS
FIVE TO LET GO WITHOUT FIVE TO
TWO. WE ARE ON SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT- DISABLED VETERANS
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE IT IS A DO
PASS AND WE'RE TO ROLL CALL VOTE
- FOURTEEN SEVENTY. I'M SORRY.
YES SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES. HI
I CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. CENTER KAMLAGER I
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYERED.
LAYERED I CENTER MICHALSKI I
CASKEY BY VOTERS SIX TO ZERO THE
PHILADELPHIA ZERO MOVING ONTO
PRO TEM ATKINS SB TEN THIRTEEN
ON BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
WINE AND DISTILLED SPIRITS.
AMENDMENTS THAT A CO AUTHOR AND
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE SENATE
BILL TEN THIRTEEN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES AYE
BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES JONES
NO CENTER KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I
SENATOR LAYERED LAYER I CENTER
WORKOUTS SKI HI CASKEY I VOTED
SIX TO ZERO CALCULUS OUT SIX
ZERO MOVING ON S. B. TEN TWENTY
SEVEN SAN DIEGO RIVER CONSERVING
INSURANCE I'M SORRY THAT WAS SIX
TO ONE- SIX TO WITH WITH SENATOR
JONES VOTING NO. I POLICY TEN
THIRTEEN IS SIX IS OUT SIX TO
ONE SB TEN TWENTY SEVEN SAN
DIEGO RIVER CONSERVANCY WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ADD A VOTING
MEMBER TO THE GOVERNING BOARD
THAT FILLS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SO
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB
TEN TWENTY SEVEN. BILLION SB TEN
THIRTY FOUR SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS THE MOTION IS TO PASS
IT IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SO
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROPE FROM
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. SB TEN
THIRTY FOUR SB TEN FORTY ONE
SALES AND USE TAX GENERAL
EXEMPTIONS THAT IS A COMMERCE
TUNING ON A ROAD COURSE THE VOTE
FROM S. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO SB TEN
FORTY ONE SB ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
WORKERS COMPENSATION LIABILITY
PRESUMPTIONS THAT DO PASS. A
MOTION WE'RE GOING TO. A ROLL
CALL. SENATE ELEVEN TWENTY STEP
THE MOST IS TO BE THIS FLOOR
CENTER. HI PORTANTINO ON SENATOR
. OF ANY. CENTER BRADFORD.
BRADFORD BY SENATOR JONES. JONES
NOTES SENATOR KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I SENATOR LAYERED.
LAYERED BY SENATOR MCCASKEY HI
MICHALSKI AYE VOTE IS FIVE TWO
ONE. FLS OUT FIVE ONE MOVING ON
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS WE HAVE AMENDMENTS
TO RESULT TO REVISE THAT M. P.
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS AND ADD CO
AUTHORS THAT BILL IS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL SO WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THEM FROM A VOTE FROM SB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN. SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE MOVING ON TO VICE CHAIR
BATES WE HAVE SB NINE OH FOUR
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE TREATMENT
IT IS IN A ROLL CALL WITH
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES OR
SUBSTITUTING THE BOAT FROM S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB NINE OH
FOUR. SB TEN SEVENTY SEVEN
GRANTS AND NON NATIVE AND
INVASIVE PLANTS. OKAY SO NINE OH
FOUR IS OUT SEVENTY ZERO. AND SO
WE'RE MOVING ON SB TEN SEVENTY
SEVEN ON GRANTS NONNATIVE
INVASIVE PLANTS THAT IS ALSO ON
A ROLL CALL WITH AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE PROVISIONS CONTINGENT UPON
AN APPROPRIATION SO THAT BILL
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TEN
SEVENTY SEVEN SO THAT FELIZ OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. SB ELEVEN NINETY
ONE PHARMA PHARMA CODE GENOMIC
TESTING I ALMOST GOT IT. IS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL SEWER
SUBSTITUTING THE BOAT FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR ELEVEN
NINETY ONE SO THAT IS OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO. SB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR
WATERSHEDS ORANGE AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES THAT IS OUT WITH
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE CONTINGENT
UPON AN APPROPRIATION ON A ROLL
CALL SEWER SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. OR
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR SO THAT'S OUT
SEVEN ZERO. SB THIRTY FORTY TWO
AGING AND THE TEASE THAT IS A DO
PASS AND THAT WERE SET ON A ROLL
CALL WERE SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TO. THIRTEEN
FORTY TWO SO THAT IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO. MOVING TO SENATOR BECKER
SB EIGHT SEVEN SIX EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM WE HAVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MAKE THE
PROGRAM CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION THAT IS OUT IN A
ROLL CALL. SO WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE VOTE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
FOR EIGHT SEVENTY SIX SO THAT'S
OUT SEVEN TO ZERO. S. B. EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN ELECTRONIC. YOU
ELECTRIC TRAINS PLANNING. OUR
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCE RELIANCE ON
CARBON EMITTING RESOURCES AND
MAKE OTHER CHANGES. AND
AMENDMENTS TO ADD A CO AUTHOR
WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL. ON
THIS TO PASS AS AMENDED BILL. SB
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES NO SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES.
JONES KNOWS SENATOR KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER HI SENATOR LAYERED.
LAYERED ICE AND- WORKOUTS SKI HI
MICHALSKI HI PHOTOS FIVE TO TWO.
PROPELLERS OUT FIVE TO TWO.
BILLION SB NINE SEVENTEEN
SEAMLESS TRANSIT TRANSFORMATION
ACTED AS A TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. BUT IT'S A ROLL CALL
VOTE. SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO I SENATOR BATES.
AYE BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES JONES
KNOWS SENATOR KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYERED.
LAYERED I CENTER WORKOUTS SKI. I
CASKEY HI IT IS SIX TO ONE. THE
BILLS OUT SIX ONE MOVING ON SB
NINE FORTY EIGHT HOUSING FINANCE
PROGRAMS DEVELOPMENT RESERVES
THEIR MOMENTS FOR AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY THAT THE BILL APPLIES
PROSPECTIVELY. AND SPECIFY
ALLOWABLE USE OF THREE REVENUES
FEE REVENUES IT IS IN A ROLL
CALL SO WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
VOTE FROM S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO. PRESS BE NO FORTY EIGHT SO
THAT BILLS OUT TWO ZERO. SB ONE
THOUSAND ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS. THERE'S A
COMMITTEE MEMBER TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THAT IS A B.
ROLL CALL SO THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO TWO WERE SUBSTITUTING
THE VOTE FROM SB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN. FOR SB ONE THOUSAND.
SB ONE THOUSAND EIGHT ON
CORRECTIONS TELEPHONE CALLS-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF MINUTES THAT DETENTION
FACILITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE AND MAKE OTHER. CHANGES
THAT BILL IS OUT ON THE B. ROLL
CALL ALSO RECEPTION THE VOTE
FROM SB TWELVE SEVENTEEN. SB ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT SO THAT'S OUT
FIVE TO TWO. SB TEN THIRTY TWO
ONE CLEAN ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
TO DO PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
AND WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL
VOTE. SENATE BILL TEN THIRTY TO
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR
BATES. BATES NO SENATOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES HI JONES I SENATOR
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I SENATOR
LAYERED. LAYERED BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI. CASKEY I.
HAVE SIX TO ONE THE PHILADELPHIA
SIX TO ONE. LIVING ON SB ELEVEN
TWELVE ON BUILDING KEY
DECARBONIZATION CHAIR CHART
CHARGES. THERE ARE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE REQUIRED CVC
ACTIVITIES ONE TIME IN NATURE.
THAT BILL IS OUT A BE ROW COSTS
OR SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE OF SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN. SB ELEVEN
TWELVE SO WITHOUT FIVE TO TWO.
S. B. ONE ONE ONE SEVEN STATE
PUBLIC DEFENDER GRANT SAID THE
TO DO PASS ON A BIRO FALSE OR
SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE FROM SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN. SB ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN TO THAT IS OUT FIVE TO
TWO. LIVING TO S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY A R. G. H. T. EMISSIONS
INTEGRATE RESOURCE PLANS OUR
MEMBERS TO ADD CO AUTHORS IT IS
A B. ROLL CALL SO THAT BILL IS
OUT. FIVE TWO TWO WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR SB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT. SB TWELVE OH THREE
ALSO ON GHG EMISSIONS STATE
AGENCY OPERATIONS- MA'AM INSTEAD
CO AUTHORS AND AGAIN THAT IS OUT
ON THE B. ROLL CALL SERVER
SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE FROM S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN. SB TWELVE OH
THREE SO THAT BILLS OUT FIVE TO
TWO SB THIRTEEN OH ONE GREEN
ENERGY MOUNT MANUFACTURING TAX
CREDITS- COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
MAKE IT CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. BILL IS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL SOURCE SUBSTITUTING
THE VOTE FOR MR LEVIN TWENTY TWO
SB THIRTEEN A ONE SO THAT THOSE
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. SB FORTINO
SEVEN CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP PROGRAM THAT BILL IS A
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL SO
RECEPTIVE TO THE VOTE FROM S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB
FOURTEEN A SEVEN STEP THOSE OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. SB FOURTEEN
NINETEEN AND HEALTH INFORMATION
IS ALSO A TO PASS. IT WHERE IT'S
A BIRO CULVER SUBSTITUTING THE
VOTE FROM SB TWELVE SEVENTEEN
FOR SB FOURTEEN NINETEEN SO THAT
THOSE OUT. TWO SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE AND PRESCHOOLS. AND
CHILD DAY CARE PROVIDERS. MEALS
TO DO PASS AND WE'RE GONNA DO A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON BEFORE. EIGHTY
ONE SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE THE MOTIONS TO PASS SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR JONES
THAT'S WHAT. CENTER KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYERED ALL
RIGHT LAYERED ICE CENTER WACO
SKI CASKEY I. SO ALL THAT ON
CALL FOR MR BRADFORD. OKAY SO
THE BILL IS ON CALL. ALL RIGHT
MOVING ON TO SENATOR PORGES SB
TWELVE SIXTY SIX INCOME TAX
CREDITS DESIGNATED WILDFIRES
OWNS- COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MAKE
IT CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
THAT PHYLLIS OUT ON A ROLL COSTS
OR SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TWELVE
SIXTY SIX SO THAT'S OUT
SEVENTEEN ZERO SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. THE MOTION IS WITH
A MAMMOTH COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
MAKE IT CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION IT PASSES ON A
ROLL CALL SO RECEPTIVE TO THE
VOTE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THAT BILL
IS OUT SEVEN. ZERO MOVING ON TO
SENATOR BRADFORD SB TEN TWENTY
ONE VEHICLE THE WEISS THIS IS A
DO PASS ON TO BE A CALL WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE FROM S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN PRESS THREE TEN
TWENTY ONE SO THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO TWO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
RESENTENCING. AS A PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL SERVER SUBSTITUTING
THE VOTE FROM SB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SO THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE
TWO TWO SB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE ON
CANNABIS TAXES IT IS A- TO PASS. WITH A ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY ONE OF. TO THE
SENATE FOR SENATE PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
SENATOR BRADFORD SENATOR JONES
JONES NO SENATOR KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYERED
LAYERED ICE CENTER WHITE HOUSE
SKI HI KELSEY HI WE HAVE FORTY
ONE CURRENTLY FORTY ONE WILL
HOLD THAT OPEN FOR CENTER
BRADFORD SB TWELVE NINETY THREE
ON INCOME TAX CREDITS. YOU KNOW
WHAT SHOULD WE- THEY SAY SHOULD
WE GO ON THE MESCALERO AND
THREATENED FOR SURE WE FOR
MULLIN ORGAN WITH EVERYTHING ON
CALL WITH REGARD PHONE
CONNECTION ENERGY DOESN'T HAVE A
ROLL CALL SO. ANYWAY SO LET JUST
SET THAT ASIDE. WILL MOVE TO
MISCARRY. THINK IT'LL SAVE US
TIME. ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE PUTTING
THAT ONE ON COLUMN MOVING ON TO
MISCARRY. SPLA A ONE CAR CAPTURE
THAT IS A DO PASS IN A ROW CALL
. A SOURCE THE VOTE FOR SB
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. FOR SB ELEVEN
A ONE SO THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE AND
BIO ENERGY. PROJECTS IT IS OUT
WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
RESERVE REMOVED OPTIONED INDEX
CONTRACTS TRANSLATION THAT BILLS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL SOURCE
SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR S. B.
ELEVEN OH NINE BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO. SB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
RESILIENCE NAVIGATOR PROGRAMS-
IT IS OUT WITH A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO INSURED GRANT FUNDING
IS DISCLOSED AS SPECIFIED IN A
ROLL CALL SERVER SUBSTITUTING
THE BOAT. FROM. ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FOUR ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
AFTER WAS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO. SB
ELEVEN FORTY TWO ON ABORTION
PRACTICAL SUPPORT FUND. THAT IS
OUT WITH A MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY FUNDING MECHANISMS AND
AMENDMENTS AT A CO AUTHOR ON THE
B. ROLL CALL. SUBSTITUTING THE
BOAT FROM SB TWELVE SEVENTEEN SB
FOURTEEN ELEVEN FORTY TWO SO
THAT BILL IS OUT. FIVE TWO TWO.
SB ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE LIABILITY
CLAIMS TIME WITHIN THE DEMANDS-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MAKE IT
INACCURATE CONTINGENT UPON
PASSAGE OF S. B. ELEVEN OH
SEVEN. SO THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL SOURCE HAVE SITTING IN
THE VOTE FROM SB ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO. FOUR S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE SO THAT'S OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO. SB TWELVE THIRTY ONE
VALLEY FEVER STANDARD DIAGNOSTIC
IT IS A DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SUBSTITUTING THE VOTE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. SB TWELVE
THIRTY ONE SO THAT IS OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO SB THIRTEEN AWAIT BY
AMERICAN PURCHASE OF DOMESTIC
FOOD PRODUCTS. IF AUTHORS MMS TO
DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION SO THAT
IT WAS ON A ROLL CALL. RECEPCI.
IN THE VOTE FROM S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO. FOR S. B. TH. OH
EIGHT SO THAT BILLS SEVEN TWO
ZERO SB THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
INTERSTATE CANNABIS AGREEMENTS.
THE DO PASS. AND IT IS A B. RO
COSTS WERE SUBSTANCE IN THE VOTE
FROM SB TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX THAT BILL IS
OUT. FIVE TWO TWO SB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE INCOME. AND CORPORATE
TAXES WORK OPPORTUNITY CREDIT WE
HAVE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO INST.
TO ALLOW THE NEW EMPLOYMENT
CREDIT IF FEDERAL W. OTC
CRITERIA ARE SATISFIED I'M GOING
TO DO A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. YOU PASS AS
AMENDED SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO HI.
PORTANTINO EYES SENATOR BATES
VOTING. AND BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES. CENTER KAMLAGER CENTER
KAMLAGER FI CENTER LAYERED
LAYERED I SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI HI CASKEY BY VOTERS. FIVE
TWO ZERO ZERO THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE IS OUT FIVE ZERO BILLION SB
FOURTEEN TEN ON SEACOR
TRANSPORTATION IMPACTED TO DO
PASS WITH A ROLL CALL. ONE
SECOND PLEASE. SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TEN THE MOTIONS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. CENTER BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES.
JONES FIVE CENTER KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYER ON EYES
AND A WHITE CAL SKI HI KANSKE BY
SIX ZERO AT THE LOS OUT SIX ZERO
MOVING ON TO SB FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE OPR GRANT PROGRAM
ANNEXATION OF UNINCORPORATED
AREAS IT COULD DO PASSED OUT ON
A ROLL CALL SERVER SUBSTITUTING
ABOUT ELEVEN TWENTY TWO SO THAT
BILL FOR FOURTEEN FORTY NINE TO
THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
AND LISTEN TO CALL IN SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE BACKER ON
PRESCHOOLS AND CHILD DAY CARE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE SENATE
FLOOR SHARE VOTING HI BATES NOT
VOTING SENATOR BRADFORD. EFFORT
BY VOTERS FIVE TWO ZERO SO
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE IS OUT FIVE
TWO ZERO WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO LIFT THE CALL ON SENATOR
BRADFORD SB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE ON
CANNABIS TAX PLEASE LIVE CALL
CALL THE ROLL SENATE BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE THE MOTIONS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR CHAIR VOTING
ON A VICE YOU'RE NOT LOADING.
CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
VOTE IS FIVE TO ONE. THAT
PHYLLIS OUT FIVE TO ONE WE'RE
GOING TO PICK UP ON SENATOR
BRADFORD'S S. B. TWELVE NINETY
THREE AND INCOME TAXATION
CREDITS CANNABIS EQUITY
APPLICATIONS AND LICENSES TO DO
PASSED WITH A ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATE
BILL TWELVE NINETY THREE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
EYES CENTER BATES YEAH. BATES NO
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. JONES NO CENTER
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER ICE AND-
LAYERED. LAYERED BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI CASKEY BY. IS
FIVE TO HELP US OUT FIVE TO SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN SECOND
DEALERS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
IT'S A DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I'M
SORRY WHAT BILLS THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN YES THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN
. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE CENTER BATES NO BATES KNOWS
CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD BY
SENATOR JONES. JONES BOATING
CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HI
CENTER LAYERED LAYERED ICE
CENTER WACO SKI HI AKOWSKI I
VOTE IS. FOUR TO ONE OR FIVE TO
ONE SORRY ABOUT THIS OUT FIVE TO
ONE LIVING ON SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FOR MEAL AND REST PERIOD
HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES IT IS TO PASS
AND IT'S GOING TO BE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FOR SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUR SO THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO TWO. SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE ON INCARCERATED
PERSONS WAGES- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO DELETE THE MAXIMUM MONTHLY
CANTEEN DRAW AND IT'S ROLL CALL
VOTE. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES
YEAH. BATES KNOWS UNDER
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES HI JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER
. KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED.
LAYER OF ICE AND A RECORD SKI HI
CASKEY VOTERS TO ONE THAT FILLS
OUT SIX TO ONE LIVING ON S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE TRAFFIC
STOPS LOW LEVEL INFRACTIONS. OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN CRISPY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE TO THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE TO TWO. SB THIRTEEN NINETY
SIX AND CREDIT REPORTING RENT
PAYMENT HISTORY EVALUATION
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO FOR SB
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX ANNAPOLIS
OUT. SEVEN ZERO. WE'VE DONE THIS
CALAVERAS ARE GONNA MOVE SENATOR
CORTESE WAS PICKING ABOUT SB
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SUPPLEMENTAL
BENEFITS. IT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE
AS IF YOU. S. EIGHT SIXTY AND
SENATE TEACHER RETIREMENT
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS. EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT. FOR ME ONE SECOND
PLEASE. SENATE BILL EIGHT SIX
EIGHT MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO I SENATOR BATES
NOBODY SENATOR BRADFORD ARE BACK
BRADFORD ICE CENTER JONES JONES
KNOWS CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER
EYES CENTER LAYERED LAYERED ICE
CENTER WORKOUTS SKI CASKEY ON.
LOTUS FIVE TO ONE THE BILL IS
OUT FIVE TO ONE MOVING ON SB
NINE NINE NINE. HEALTH COVERAGE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS IT WERE SEVENTEEN THE
ROLE FROM S. B. TWELVE SEVENTEEN
FOR SB NINE NINE NINE TO THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO SB
TWELVE NINETY FOUR WORKFORCE
WELLNESS CENTER SANTA CLARA
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION PRETTY.
THAT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE
BILL TWELVE NINETY FOUR THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES NO CENTER BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES JONES
KNOWS CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER
I SENATOR LAYERED. LAYER I
SENATOR RICK OWSKI HI CASKEY HI
FOLKS FIVE TO THAT BILLS OUT
FIVE. TO LIVING ON SB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN LOW EMBODIED CARBON
BUILDING MATERIALS THAT IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. MOTIONS SENATE
BILL TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES NO SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES YOU
KNOW JONES KNOWS SENATOR
KAMLAGER. I'M MORE ICE LEAHY.
LAYERED AND RECOUNTS HI MAKOWSKI
BY VOTERS FIVE TO. FILL US OUT
FOR FIFTY MOVING ON AS THIRTEEN.
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION AREA PERMITS
. FOR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
SB ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN TO THAT BILL IS
OUT. SEVEN TWO ZERO. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS RUSHES TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR IT IS OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO MOVING ON SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE HOMELESS STUDENTS INCOME
PROGRAMS IT IS A MOTION WITH A
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO REQUIRE
DSS TO ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM
SPECIFY THE MONTHLY PAYMENT
AMOUNT AND REMOVE THE CHOIR
MEANT FOR C. SACK TO SEEK
FEDERAL WAIVERS. IT IS
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE SO THAT BILL IS OUT AS
AMENDED FIVE TWO TWO WILL BE ON
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING LOCAL SOLAR
PROGRAMS WE HAVE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ADD A SUNSET OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN S. B. FOR SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE SO THAT
BILL IS OUT. FIVE TWO TWO. THE
SENATOR DODD. SB EIGHT THREE
THREE COMMUNITY ENERGY
RESILIENCY ACTED AS A THROUGH
PASS. AND REMOTE SUBSTITUTING
THE MOTION FROM ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FOR EIGHT THIRTY THREE SO
THAT MONTH MONTH BILL PASSES
SEVEN ZERO. EIGHT FORTY TWO
DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT IS A
DO PASS- AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FOR SB EIGHT FORTY TWO STEP
BILLS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. SB
EIGHT FORTY SIX AN ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE DELIVERY SERVICE
PERMITS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED PER AUTHORED TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION INCREASE FINES
AND FEES. REVISED R. B. S.
TRAINING COURSE REQUIREMENTS AND
MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING CHANGES.
RECEPTION IN THE ROLE FROM SB
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR FOUR EIGHT
FORTY SIX SO THAT THOSE OUT
SEVENTY ZERO AS A MAN. SB EIGHT
FIFTY SIX ON WILD PIGS HAVE BEEN
WAITING ALL DAY TO SAY WILD
PIGS. WE SAY THAT AGAIN WILD
PIGS. WAIT NOT ONLY ARE THEY-
THEIR V. WHILE PEGS BECAUSE IT'S
WILD PIGS VALIDATIONS. SO ON
EIGHT FIFTY SIX AM I SAY ONE
MORE TIME WHILE PIG VALIDATIONS
WE HAVE AUTHORS AMENITIES TICTOC
BY MAKE SURE ALL WEEK WE HAVE A
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED TO MAKE THE
REPORT CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES. IT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES NO BATES NO CENTER
BRADFORD. OUR BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. SENATOR KAMLAGER
HI KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED
LAYERED I SENATOR WAKO SKI.
MAKOWSKI I. INVALID WHILE. I
THINK THERE SHOULD BE A SET
INQUIRY FIGURE OUT HOW YOU
DETERMINE THE VALIDITY OF A
WHILE I REALLY DON'T WANT TO BE
ON THAT CAN I NOMINATE SLEPT
SENATOR LEHRER TO CHAIR THAT.
THERE WE GO VOTERS FIVE ONE.
THAT BILL IS OUT OF FIVE TO ONE
WHO SAYS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DOESN'T HAVE FUN. S.
B. AND WE'RE GOING RIGHT FROM
PEGS THE HUNTING S. B. AND NO
CONNECTION. SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
JUNIOR HUNTING LICENCES- AND
THAT IS A DO PASS AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. TO EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE AND SO THAT BILL IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO. PHARMACISTS
PHARMACIES MOBILE UNITS IT IS A
DEEP PASS RECEPTIONS IN THE ROLE
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN TO ZERO. SB NINE TWENTY
SIX IS NOT PRESCRIBED FIRE
LIABILITY ERIC COMMITTEE MANAGED
AT A CO AUTHOR. AND SO THAT BILL
IS OUT FOR STUFF IN THE ROLL
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FIRST
NINE TWENTY SIX OPPOSE OUT SEVEN
TWO ZERO. SB TEN FORTY NINE
TRANSPORTATION RESILIENCY
PROGRAM WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO REVISE FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS DELETE PRIVATIZATION
REQUIREMENTS AND ALLOW
IMPLEMENTATION THROUGH
GUIDELINES WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE ON. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
FOR TEN FORTY NINE SO THAT FLOWS
OUT. SEVEN ZERO. SB TEN FIFTY ON
STATE ROUTE THIRTY SEVEN TOLL
BRIDGE ACT. IT IS TO DO PASS AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTEEN. TEN
FIFTY SO THAT FILLS OUT FIVE TO
TWO SB ELEVEN OH SEVEN VEHICLES
INSURANCE. WE HAVE AMENDMENTS
PER AUTHORED A NARROW THE
MOTORIST COVERAGE STUDY AND
AMEND TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
ENACTMENT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE FOR THOSE OF YOU AT HOME.
AND FOR MISTER MCCAMLY WE SEE
HOW WE JOIN THOSE TWO BILLS
TOGETHER. YOU'RE FOLLOWING. THE
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
1-217-410-1107 SO THAT BILLS
OUT. FIVE TWO TWO LIVING ON THE
SENATOR GARAGE- SB NINE FIFTY
ONE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
PLAYED FINALLY LEAVE. WEEKLY
BENEFIT AMOUNTS WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES REMOVED THE INTERIM.
BENEFIT AND DELAY THE START OF
ENHANCEMENT BENEFITS UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THAT WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN TO THAT BILL
IS. WITH THE SUBSTITUTED ROLE
FIVE TO TWO. SB TEN FORTY FOUR
EMPLOYER STATE OF EMERGENCY
RETALIATION WE HAVE AUTHORS
MEMBERS WHO ACCEPT EMERGENCY
RESPONSE WORKERS IN IT ALL
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS. WE ARE
LETTING THAT OUT ON A- SUBSIDY
IN THE ROLE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR TEN FORTY FORCE
THAT PULLS OUT. FIVE TWO TWO SB
TEN FIFTY EIGHT THIS DISABILITY
INSURANCE PAID LEAVE APPLICANT
DATA. IS OF DO PASS. WITH A ROLL
CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
. HI PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR
BATES. SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD
DODD SENATOR JONES JONES NO
CENTER KAMLAGER. SEVEN HUNDRED
SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY EIGHT.
YEAH HI CAMMALLERI CENTER
LAYERED. LAYERED I CENTER LIKE
ASKING HI MICHALSKI FIVE VOTE IS
FIVE TO ONE I THINK THE EYES
HAVE IT. ALL RIGHT FIVE FIVE TWO
ONE IT IS OUT SB THIRTEEN
HUNDRED FOSTER YOUTH SSI TO DO
PASSWORDS IN THE RAW FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TO. THIRTEEN HUNDRED TO
THAT THOSE OUT SEVEN ZERO SB
THIRTEEN OH NINE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING DISPLAYS EXEMPTIONS
FOR SPORTS ARENAS- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ALL THEIR MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED REQUIRE CALTRANS TO
MAKE COMPLIANCE DETERMINATION
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS- THEY'RE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. TO MEANT
TO LIMIT EXEMPTIONS TO EXISTING
ARENAS AND DELETE EXPANSION OF
PROMISES- WE ARE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN TO THAT BILL AS
AMENDED IS OUT FIVE TWO TWO. SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
THERE'S AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND THERE'S A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. SENATOR BRADFORD
. BRADFORD SENATOR JONES.
SENATOR KAMLAGER KAMLAGER EYES
SENATOR LAYERED LAYERED ICE
SENATOR WHITEHOUSE HI CASKEY I
SUPPOSE FIVE TO ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT FIVE ZERO. THAT WAS THE
CALIFORNIA PRESS THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE ARE MOVING ON A THIRTEEN
SIXTY FOUR UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
VENDORS IT IS A TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES VOTING. SENATOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES. JONES KNOWS SENATOR
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES CENTER
LAYERED ON. LAYERED ICE CENTER
WHITE HOUSE E. HI MY CASKEY ARE
. BUT A VOTE IS FIVE TO ONE
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOURS OUT FIVE TO
ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN OH SIX
EXCLUDING EMPLOYEE BINDING
ARBITRATION IS A DEEP PASS OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TO FOURTEEN OH SIX
FOR THE BILL IS OUT. SEVEN ZERO
MOVING ON TO SENATOR EGGMAN WE
HAVE SB EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
REIMBURSEMENT IT IS TO DO PASS
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR EIGHT
SEVENTY SEVEN SETTLES OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO. SB EIGHT EIGHT TWO
ADVISORY COUNCIL IN INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF COUNCIL MEMBERS TO
NINE OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
SB EIGHT EIGHT TO SET THOSE OUT
SEVEN TO ZERO. SB NINE TWO NINE
DATA COLLECTION MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WE HAVE AUTHORS MEMBERS
TO CLARIFY SPECIFIED DATA
REQUIREMENTS SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO SB
NINE TWENTY NINE TO THAT BILL IS
OUT AS AMENDED SEVEN TWO ZERO SB
NINE SEVENTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT. IS A DO PASS OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB NINE
SEVENTY SO THAT BILL IS OUT OF
SEVEN TO ZERO SB ONE THOUSAND
THREE ON TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
TRAINING PROGRAM SIR MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED TO SPECIFY PROGRAMS
ELIGIBLE FOR CERTIFICATION THE
CLARIFY THE CERTIFICATION
VOLUNTARY NATURE. SO THAT BILL
IS OUT SEVEN ZERO AS WE
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM
1-122-401-0003 AS AMENDED AS P.
R. ONE THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
TERMINATION OF TENANCY ABUSE
FILE VIOLENCE WE HAVE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO REMOVE THE PROVISION
THAT MAKES SPECIFIC EVIDENCE IN
MATERIAL TO AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE.
THAT BILL IS OUT AS WE
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR TEN SEVENTEEN ON A
FIVE TO VOTE SB TEN SIXTY FIVE
ABANDONED AND DERELICT VESSELS
CITIZEN CAN PASS WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TEN SIXTY
FIVE SETTLES OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO.
SB ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR FACILITY
FACILITIES FOR MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS DATABASE
OF AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO INCLUDE
SPECIFIED. STAKEHOLDERS WERE UP
TO DO THE ROLE FROM TWENTY TWO.
ELEVEN FIFTY FOUR SAID BILLS
OUT. SEVEN IS. SB TWELVE ON
MILITARY TRUMP RESET. WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL VOTE AND THEY'RE SOFT
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY THAT THE RESENTENCING IS
ONLY AVAILABLE IF PASSED
MILITARY TRAUMA HAS NOT BEEN
CONSIDERED IN PRIOR PROCEEDINGS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATE
BILL TWELVE OH NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO. HI
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES.
BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES HI
JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER I SENATOR LEBRETON
LAYERED ICE CENTER WORKOUTS SKI
HI HOUSE KIOSK SEVEN ZERO.
ABILITY OUT SEVEN ZERO. WOMEN SB
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN INVOLUNTARY
COMMITMENT INTENSIVE TREATMENT.
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN SO THAT BILLS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO. TO THE FLOOR SB
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. AGAIN WE'RE SUBJECTING
THE ROLE FROM S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FRESH BE TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT TO THAT BILL IS
OUT. SEVEN TWO ZERO. THAT'S
THIRTY WILL BETTER CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WE HAVE A MEMBERS
FOR AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES PERCEPTION THE ROLE FROM
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. SB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN AFTER WITHOUT
SEVEN TO ZERO SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE HOUSING CREDIT HISTORY OF
PERSONS RECEIVING HOUSING
SUBSIDIES. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
A WE'RE GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLE FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE SHEKELS OUT
FIVE TO TWO. SB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES GRAVELY
DISABLED PERSONS. WE HAVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO DELETE
EXPLANATORY LANGUAGE AND WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO TUNING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN CEPHALUS OUT SEVEN. ZERO
MOVING ON TO SENATOR GLAZER ON
TAXATION RENTER'S CREDIT IS DUE
PASS RECEPTION ON THE ROLL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR EIGHT
FORTY THREE SO THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN TWO ZERO SB NINE ELEVEN
CALIFORNIA'S BOARD TO FUND
PUBLIC INTEREST MEDIA IF AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO ADD DEFINITIONS
INCLUDING NEWS WORKERS REVISED
CRITERIA FOR AWARDING GRANTS.
AND A CO AUTHOR OF. AMENDS TO
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES. THAT IS
A- TWELVE SEVENTEEN SUBSTITUTION
FOR NINE ELEVEN SO THAT BILL IS
OUT FIVE TWO TWO. THE ROLL CALL
FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN AS BEING
THE AND AS AMENDED SB NINE
TWENTY FOUR. SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION REPORTING
WITH A DO PASS RECEPTIONS IN THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
NINE TWENTY FOUR SET THOSE OUT
SEVEN TWO. ZERO SB NINE THIRTY
SIX CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
COURSE FOR FORESTRY TRAINING
CENTER. RECEPTION ROLL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR NINE
THIRTY SIX ORDERS TO DO PAST
SEVEN TO ZERO. SB TEN TWELVE ON
STATE PARKS OPEN FIRES. IT IS
BETWEEN THE ROLE FROM A TWENTY
TWO TO TEN TWELVE AND SO THAT IS
A DO PAST SEVEN ZERO. THIS
FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE CAMPING
CONTRA AGENTS OFFICERS. OF
AMENDMENTS THAT A CO AUTHOR
WE'RE GOING TO DO A ROLL CALL IN
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES SAWYER. SENATOR
KAMLAGER ALL RIGHT KAMLAGER EYES
CENTER LAYERED ON IT LATER I
SENATOR WAKO SKI HI. KELSEY HI
THOSE FIVE TO ZERO. THAT BILLS
OUT. FIVE TWO ZERO LEON SP
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WE HAVE A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO SPECIFY
THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE PREVIOUSLY
BEEN FOUND FACTUALLY INNOCENT
MUST APPLY. TO DOJ FOR
CERTIFICATE AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES. OR SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TO
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. THAT BILL
IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO AS A
MATTER. SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
REMOTE ACCESSIBLE VOTE BY MAIL
SYSTEMS IT IS IT TO PASS RECEPCI
TO THE ROLE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR EIGHT FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SO THAT BILLS OUT FOR.
FIVE TO MOVING ON THE SENATOR
GONZALEZ S. B. TEN NINETEEN
MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS.
WE HAVE A MEMBERS TO CHANGE THE
FREQUENCY OF THE ASSESSMENT. AND
SPECIFIED REPORT TO ONCE EVERY
THREE YEARS. WE'RE SUBSIDIZING
THE ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
FOR TEN NINETEEN TO THAT THOSE
OUT SEVENTY ZERO AS A MAN. SB
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN ON CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS YOU HAVE AMENDMENTS
TO ADD A CO AUTHOR. AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN STEP THOSE OUT. SEVEN TWO
ZERO S. B. ELEVEN OH FOUR GOBIZ
OFFICE OF. EIGHT IS IT TO PASS
SUCH. FOR ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
ALLOW- FORCE THAT BILL OUT.
SEVEN TWO ZERO. SB ALLY TWENTY
ENTRY. SYSTEM NEED TO. THIS TO
PASS IN A ROLE VOTE. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE THE MOTIONS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES AYE BATES AYE
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD ICE
CENTER JONES. SENATOR KAMLAGER
HI KAMLAGER ICE CENTER LAYER ON
LAYER I SENATOR RICK OWSKI HI
CASKET BY SIX ZERO. BILLS OUT
SIX ZERO. WE'RE MOVING ON TO SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE PUBLIC
RETIREMENT SYSTEM FOSSIL FUEL
DIVESTMENT IT IS A DO PASSED
WITH A ROLL CALL VOTE SENATE
BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
AYE SENATOR BATES. BATES NO
CENTER BRADFORD ADVERTISED
EDITOR JONES JONES KNOWS CENTER
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I SENATOR
LAYERED HI LARRY I SENATOR RICK
OWSKI NOT VOTING. ALL YEAH. OKAY
HI HOLD ON WHILE SO LET'S GO
BACK AND START AT THE TOP. FIVE
EIGHT THIRTY ONE HOW DO YOU WANT
TO DO MARK. I'M. THIS IS THE
FOSSIL FUEL TO THIS SO IT IS.
ONE SECOND. IF YOU BRADFORD FOR
CLOSE DOWN THE WHOLE. TITLE I
MEAN I. WHITE HOUSE YOU'RE NOT.
HOW ARE ON THIS THAT I WAS BORN
. OKAY FOR. MEMBERS OF. ONE
SEVEN I MET MIGHT OFFICE BECAUSE
IF YOU'RE COMMITTEE STAY IN
THEIR BRADFORD BUT THE THEN.
WHAT'S I MEAN I'VE ALREADY HAD
RIGHT LET'S LET'S DO THE VOTE
AGAIN ANIMAL PUT ON CALL. WHAT
PORTANTINO WHY. I PORTANTINO
WASN'T HIGH SENATOR BATES IS A
NO NO CENTER BRADFORD. OF VOTING
SENATOR JONES NO NO SAID MR
JONES KNOWS CENTER KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED
LAYERED BY. VOTERS THREE TO TWO
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. CALL ALL
RIGHT WE ON THE S. B. TWELVE
SIXTEEN DEEP DEEP FAITH WORKING
GROUP'S IT IS A DO PASS WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TWELVE
SIXTEEN THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO SB TWELVE THIRTY THREE DMV
REPORT ON UNSERVED OR
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS IT IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. TWELVE THIRTY
THREE. ALL THIS. SENATE BILL
TWELVE THIRTY THREE THE MOTIONS
DO PASSED THE SENATE FLOOR.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES LEADING CENTER
BRADFORD ADVERTISED EDITOR JONES
JONES KNOWS SENATOR KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED
LAYERED I SENATOR Y. CASKEY HI
CASKEY BY. LOTUS FIVE TO ONE.
ALL RIGHT SB TWELVE THIRTY THREE
IS OUT FIVE TO ONE SB TWELVE
FIFTY ONE OFFICE OBSERVE THE
FOUGHT EQUITIES ADVOCATE IT IS
MEMBERS TO ADD CO AUTHORS OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR SB TWELVE
FIFTY ONES THAT BILLS OUT FIVE
TO TWO. S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE CALIFORNIA TECH WITTY
INNOVATION PROGRAM WE HAVE A
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES IN DIRECT GO
BASED PRIORITIZE APPLICANTS.
THAT MEET SPECIFIED CRITERIA
THERE'S A ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO ALL
RIGHT PORTANTINO EYES CENTER
BATES. NOBODY SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD DODD SENATOR JONES W.
SENATOR KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I
SENATOR LAYERED ON LAYER OF ICE
AND A RECOUNT. FOR BY. FIVE TWO
ZERO RIGHT NOT THERE TWENTY FIVE
YES I PUT THEIR OWN- SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO BY GONZALEZ AND CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM SALES AND
USE TAX VEHICLE EXEMPTION
THERE'S A MEMBERS TO ADD A CO
AUTHOR. IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO EYES
CENTER BATES. BATES NO CENTER
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES JONES KNOWS CENTER
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES CENTER
LAYERED. LAYERED ICE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI THE CASKET BY
. IT'S FIVE TWO TWO FIVE TWO TWO
THAT FLOWS OUT TO HOLD ON ONE
SECOND. YEAH WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
THIRTY SECOND. SPONSORED BY
STATE PUT. TO JUST BEFORE
SHOOTING. I'VE GOT.
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS VERGER
RECESS FOR FIVE MINUTES.
PERFICIENT COMMITTEE WILL READ.
MOVING ON THE MS GROVE SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE STATEWIDE
IMAGINATION LIBRARY PROGRAM IT
IS OUT WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE. SO THAT IS
OUT SEVENTY TWO SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR INCOME TAX CREDITS
FOSTER YOUTH IT IS A DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR THAT PHYLLIS OUT SEVENTY
TWO. MOVING TO SENATOR HERTZBERG
SB NINE OH THREE CALIFORNIA
REHABILITATION OVERSIGHT BOARD
WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR NINE OH THREE SO
THAT BILL IS OUT. SEVEN TWO ZERO
SB NINE SIXTY SEVEN HEALTH
COVERAGE TAX RETURNS IT IS A DO
PASS RECEPTION ROLL FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO SB NINE SIXTY SEVEN
SAMPLES OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO SB
NINE SEVEN THREE SS P.
ADMINISTRATION. WERE SUBSIDY IN
THE ROLL FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
FOR NINE SEVENTY THREE SO THAT
BILL IS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SEVEN TWO ZERO SB NINE EIGHTY
NINE CLIMATE CHANGE PREPAREDNESS
RESILIENCY IN JOBS. THAT IS A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR NINE EIGHTY NINE
SO THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO
SB TEN FOURTEEN ENHANCE CLINICAL
INTEGRATED PROGRAM- THAT IS A
SUBZERO FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN
FOR SB TEN FOURTEEN THAT BILL IS
OUT. I'VE TO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR ELECTRICITY TRANSMISSION
AND INTER. INTER CONNECTION
THERE'S A MEMBERS PROFIT REQUIRE
CPUC TO ONLY IDENTIFY PROJECTS
FOR PRIVATIZATION I SPECIFIED
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAID CO
AUTHORS IT ISA ROLL CALL VOTE
ON. ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN SEVEN FOUR MOTIONS
TO PAY A SOME TO THIS FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
I CENTER BATES. BATES AYE
SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. SENATOR KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYERED.
LAYERED I CENTER WEIGHT CASKEY.
CASKET BY VOTERS SIX TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN. IT IS
SUBSTRING THE ROLE FOR SB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
SO THAT THOSE OUT FIVE TWO S.
SEVEN SEMI THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
FIREARM PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
OVER THIRTEEN THIRTEEN THAT I
SAY WHAT IT WAS FOR. LOCAL
PUBLIC EMPLOYER INNOVATION
HEALTH BENEFIT DISCRIMINATION SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN FIREARM-PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
PERCEPTION IN THE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN TO THAT BILLS OUT
FIVE TO TWO SB THIRTEEN FORTY
PROPERTY TAXATION NEW
CONSTRUCTION SOLAR ENERGY TO
ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
LICENSE BATES. BATES KNOWS
SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES JONES KNOWS
SENATOR KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I
LAYERED LAYERED I SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE. CASKEY VOTERS FIVE TWO
ADD GOES OUT FIVE TWO TWO SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCY ALTERNATIVE
CONTRACTING PROCEDURE PILOT IT
IS A ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
AYE SENATOR BATES NOBODY CENTER
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES JONES BY SENATOR KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER BY SENATOR LAYER ON
LAYER I SENATOR MURKOWSKI
MAKOWSKI. FIVE SIX TWO ZERO.
THAT IS OUT SIXTY. S. FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA FAMILY
HOME CONSTRUCTION HOMEOWNERSHIP
BOND ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SEP TWO THE ROLE FROM S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO TWO WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
TO SB FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE WHICH
WE PASSED THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS BUT IT'S STILL A
BILL. THAT AMENDS THE POLITICAL
FORM ACT AND WE ARE PASSED THE
LAST DAY TO AMEND P. R. A. BILLS
SO WITHOUT OJECTION WE'RE GOING
TO RECONSIDER THE VOTE ON SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE. ANY
OBJECTION TO RECONSIDERING THE
VOTE ON SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
NINETEEN NO OBJECTION WE
RECONSIDER THAT ON A SEVEN OH
VOTE NOW WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE
ROLE IN SB FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE
WITH THE STRAIGHT TO PASS A
MOTION. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY NINE
THE MOTIONS DO PASSED THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO EYES CENTER BATES.
YOU'RE NOT LOADING BEFORE. IT'S
NOT. GLAZERS GLAZER SENATOR
GLAZERS FOR THIRTEEN SENATOR
BATES NOT. CENTER BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES.
JONES NOT VOTE CENTER KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED
LAYERED ICE WHITE HOUSE BY CAL
SKI BY THE IS FOR TWO ZERO. THAT
BILL NOW IS OUT FIVE ZERO THE TO
PASS ON A DO PASS.
THIS THIS. YEAH WE'LL TRY OF.
THIRTY ONE WAY TO THE EARTH OF.
WE WILL TRY LET'S LIFT THE BILL
NUMBER ONE SENATE. RIGHT LET
SEVENTY THREE WE'RE GONNA LIVE
OF CALL ROLL CALL ON SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THE CURRENT LOTUS
THREE TO TWO HOURS SHARE VOTING
ON A VICE CHAIR VOTING NO
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ WITH LIFTING THE CALL.
SENATOR OWSKI NOBODY OKAY.
REFERRED BY VOTERS FOR TWO THE
BILL IS OUT FORTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
BEARING WITH US DURING THAT I
PURCHASED. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
MOVING ON THE SENATOR HUESO
THAT'LL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO- SB
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS UNIVERSAL
SERVICE PROGRAMS FOR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN STEP THOSE OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO. SB NINE NINETY FOUR ALL
COUNTY OR FOR RELEASE WE HAVE
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY WHEN CDC
ARE IS REQUIRED TO APPROVED
PAROLE TRAVELER TRANSFER REQUEST
FOR SIMPSON ROLL FROM S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN THE S. B. NINE
NINETY SO THAT'S THAT WAS OUT
FIVE TWO TWO. SB TEN TWENTY
EIGHT VIA MONTEZUMA IT IS A DO
PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB TEN
TWENTY EIGHT. AND SO THAT THOSE
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO S. V. LET OH
FIVE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL HOW
FINANCE ARE AGENCIES ME.
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FRESHFIELD IN A
FIVE SET UP THOSE OUT FIVE TO
TWO. SB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE STATE
ROUTE ONE TWENTY FIVE TOLL
PROJECT IT IS A DO PASS AND IT'S
A ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO. I EYES BAYH. NOBODY
CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES HI JOE I SENT
KAMLAGER. HI KAMLAGER CENTER
LAYERED. LAYERED SENATOR CASSIDY
. CASKET BY OF SIX TO. THAT OUT
SICK. TO BILLION SB EIGHTY USE
TIRES IS TO DO. FOR IN THE ROLE
ELEVEN TWO. ELEVEN EIGHTY STEP
BILLS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO S. B. OH
EIGHT. UTILITY ASSIST
STREAMLINED APPLICATION IT IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL TWO
WHO MOTIONS TO PASS THE SAN
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO HI
FOURTEEN AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE SENATOR JONES JONES I
SENATOR COME. HI KAMLAGER ICE
LAYERED LAYERED I SAID
WHITEHOUSE HI BECAUSE BY HIS
ZERO. ALL RIGHT SENATE BILL OUR
- SEVEN TWO ZERO MOVING ON SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION STAY.
SEVENTEEN THE ROLE FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY. OR FORTY SEVEN THAT BILL
OUT TWO Z. S. THIRTY FIFTY NINE
IS TRAFFIC STOPS REGISTRATION
TABS IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THIS
FLOOR SENATOR PORTENT. I FORTINO
CENTER. SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD BY SENATOR JONES JONES
I SENATOR KAMLAGER. YEAH
KAMLAGER I SAID LAYERED LAYER
ICE CENTER BY SKI HI WE CAN I
WHO SIX TO. AFTER WAS OUT IS.
GOING ON B. THIRTEEN H. THREE
ELECTRICS FACILITIES TO DO PASS
RECEPTIONS ROLE ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FOR TWELVE OR THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE APPLE OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO SENATOR TADO EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN IS A PASS RECEPTIONS FROM
ELEVEN TO TWO FOR EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN SAMPLES OUT SEVEN ZERO SB
EIGHT NINETY TWO CYBER SECURITY
PREPAREDNESS AGRICULTURE WATER
INDUSTRIES IT'S A ROLL CALL
VOTE. SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY
TWO THE MOTIONS TO PASSED THE
SENATE CENTER. ONLINE FOR AYE
SENATOR. BATES SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD ICE JONES JONES CENTER
KAMLAGER I LAYERED LAYER I
ENTERING. I THE COSBY BY VOTERS
FIVE TWO HAVE SERVICE OUT FIVE
TO TWO. MOVING ON SPT TWENTY
THREE HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE AS-
AND TRAINING TO. SUB TO OF SPLA
TWENTY FOR TEN TWENTY THREE SEP
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB TEN
TWENTY NINE ONE HEALTH PROGRAM.
IT IS A SUBSTITUTE OF ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR TEN TWENTY NINE
SO THAT BILLS IS A DO PASS ON
THE SEVEN ZERO VOTE SB TEN SIXTY
SIX FARMWORKERS DROUGHT
RESILIENCY. SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE OF S. B. TWELVE SEVEN FOR
TEN SIXTY SO THAT PHIL IS OUT
FIVE TO TWO. SB ELEVEN I TO ME
TEN EIGHTY FOUR PROPERTY
OWNERSHIP FORMS. TO DO PASS ON
WHICH ROLE FROM. TWENTY FOR TEN
EIGHTY FOUR THAT BILL OUT TO
ZERO S. TEN NINETY- RESEARCH
SYSTEM SEPT THE ROLE FROM S. LET
TWENTY FRESH TEN NINETY THAT
FILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO. SB TEN
NINETY ONE FAMILY FINDING ENDING
WERE SO THE ROLE FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR TEN NINETY ONE
THAT FILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB TEN
NINETY TWO DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES FAIR HEARINGS.
SEVENTEEN ROLLED ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FOR TEN NINETY TWO THAT
PULLS OUT SEVEN ZERO. SB TWELVE
NINETEEN WATER LAWS AND AGENCIES
. AS A ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE
BILL TWELVE NINE. MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO NINE FOURTEEN EYES
AND BATES. BATES I'D AND A
BRADFORD. BRADFORD ICE IN JONES
. SENATOR KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I
CENTER LAYERED. LAYER I SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE BEHIND CHELSEA FIVE
SIX ZERO IF OUT SIX ZERO MOVING
ON S. B. SHOULD AFTER JONES SB
EIGHT NINETY FOUR OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES THIS IS WHAT TRY NUMBER
FOUR. THREE WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR EIGHT
NINETY FOUR THAT PHYLLIS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO S. B. NINE FORTY
SIX CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS
RECEPTION IN THE ROLE OF ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR A NINE FORTY SIX
THAT BLOWS OUT. SEVEN ZERO S. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CARDIAC SCREENING PILOT
PROGRAM WE HAVE A MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES WERE SUBSTANTIVE MOTION
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TO. ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE THAT BILL IS OUT AS
AMENDED SEVENTY ZERO LIVING ON
THE SENATOR COM LONGER ON CAL
WORKS ELIGIBILITY WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON SB NINE NINE SIX.
SENATE BILL NINE NINE SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES
VOTING. CENTER BRADFORD BRADFORD
DODD SENATOR JONES. CENTER
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES
INTERLAYER. LAYERED ICE CENTER
ACCOUNT. MAKOWSKI BY VOTERS FIVE
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT FOR TWO
ZERO LIVING ON S. B. TEN FIFTY
TWO ON THE BALD WITH A CONSERVE
WE HAVE A AND THEN SAID CO
AUTHORS WERE IN THE ROLE FROM
TWENTY TWO FOR TWO FIFTY TWO SO
THAT BILL IS OUT. A SEVENTY S.
B. TEN FIFTY FIVE CHILD SUPPORT
ENFORCEMENT LICENSE SUSPENSIONS
WE HAVE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
TECHNICAL AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
EMOTION FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN TO
TEN FIFTY FIVE SO THE VOTERS IS
TO THE BILL IS OUT AS AMENDED
FIVE TO TWO ELEVENTH NINE
PRISON. WE HAVE AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE THE BILL SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION AND IT'S A ROLL
CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO I'M BATES.
SENATOR BRADFORD ADVERTISED
EDITOR JONES SENATOR KAMLAGER
SENATOR LAYERED ART SORRY
KAMLAGER ICE LAYER ON LAYER OF
ICE AND A RECORD SKY ACCOUNTS
KEEP BY VOTERS FIVE ZERO AT
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO FOR MOVING
ON ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN- MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED AT A CO AUTHOR
RECEPTION IN THE ROLE OF ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN STEP BILLS OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO AS AMENDED SB TWELVE FORTY
FIVE L. A. COUNTY ABORTION
ACCESS SAFE HAVEN PILOTS HAVE
AUTHORS A MEMBER SAID A CO
AUTHOR AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN.
THAT BILL ITSELF AS AMENDED FIVE
TO TWO SB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
PRISONS RELEASE ALLOWANCES WE
HAVE AN AMENDMENT TO REDUCE THE
RELEASE ALLOWS THE THIRTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND WE'RE GONNA
DO A ROLL CALL VOTE. THIRTY OH
FOR THEM. TO PASSAGE AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FOR SENATOR PORTENT.
HI FOURTEEN AYE SENATOR BATES.
SENATOR BREAUX. ARE BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR. I'M GOING CENTER
KAMLAGER. SENATOR LET KAMLAGER
ICE IN EARLIER ON LAYER OF AN
EARTHQUAKE OWSKI HI ACCOUNTS I
VOTERS FIVES AFTER THOSE OUT FOR
ZERO SPEAKER NINE ONE I CAP AND
TRADE LINKAGES TO STATE TO PASS
A MORE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FOR SEVENTY FOR THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE OF THOSE OUT FIVE TO
BE ON THE SENATOR LAYERED SB
EIGHT FIFTY CALPERS SPECIAL
DEATH BENEFITS. IS TO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB EIGHT
WATER DIVERSION UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSIONS PERCEPTION THE ROLE
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO RATE
EIGHTY THAT FILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
S. B. EIGHT EIGHT FIVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FOSTER YOUTH SUPPORT
THAT BILL IS SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
THAT BILL IS OUT OF SEVEN TO
ZERO. SB EIGHT NINETY FIVE
NONPROFIT RECYCLERS RECEPTION IN
THE ROLE FROM 1-122-489-5890
FIVE THAT FLOWS OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO SB NINE FORTY FIVE FALCONRY
THAT'S THE OTHER WORDS I'VE BEEN
WAITING TO SAY ALL THE FALCONRY.
WE'RE STEPS IN THE ROLE FROM SB
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB NINE
FORTY FIVE THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO SB NINE FIFTY
SEVEN PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD SANTA CRUZ
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT. THE ROLE
TWELVE SEVEN OR NINE FIFTY SEVEN
THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO TWO SB
NINE SIXTY THREE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL AND HISTORICAL
INDICTMENT IS A SUBSIDY THE ROLE
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR NINE
SIXTY THREE SEPARATE OUTS TWO
ZERO SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
CONSERVATION RANCHING INCENTIVES
WERE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TO. SEVENTY SEVEN
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO S. TEN
TWENTY CLEAN ENERGY JOBS AND
AFFORDABILITY ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SEP TWO THE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR TEN TWENTY
AND SO THAT FILLS OUT FIVE TO
TWO S. B. ELEVEN FORTY FIVE AM
G. EMISSIONS DASHBOARD WE HAVE
AMENDMENTS CO AUTHORS FOR
SUBSTANTIVE THE ROLE FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TO ELEVEN FORTY FIVE THAT
PHYLLIS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT STATE DRINKING
WATER STATE REVOLVING FUND. ALL
LEVINSON HE TO ELEVEN A. EIGHT
THAT PHYLLIS OUT. SEVEN TWO ZERO
MOVING TO SAN LATE S. B. SIX
NINE HOME OR PARK MANAGER
TRAINING. WE HAVE COMMITTEE WE A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR OF I MINUTES
TRAINING. AT ALLOW EACH EITHER
STYLISH PENALTY FOR. NOT
COMPLIANCE WITH HAVE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO TRAIN REQUIRED. ONE
MATT WHY MANAGER PER PART. IT IS
A SUBSTITUTE ROLE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR EIGHT SIXTY NINE
SO THAT BILL IS OUT. FIVE TWO
TWO SB NINE SIXTEEN SEXUAL
ASSAULT VICTIMS RIGHTS IT IS A
DEEP PASS RECEPTION ROLL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. NINE SIXTEEN
THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB
NINE THIRTY ONE DETERRING UNION
MEMBERSHIP VIOLATIONS WE HAVE A
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO SPECIFIED
THAT PENALTY REVENUE. WOULD BE
DEPOSITED INTO THE GENERAL FUND
WERE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN. FOR NINE
THIRTY ONES THAT WAS OUT FIVE
TWO SB NINE FIVE FIVE EXCUSED
ABSENCE FOR CIVIC OR POLITICAL
EVENTS. TO DO PASS WERE SUBSIDY
IN THE ROLE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN. OR NINE FIFTY FIVE
THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TO SB NINE
SEVENTY SIX. UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
ACT WE HAVE A VERY MUCH AUTHORED
MAKE THE PROGRAM CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION. AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. IT IS A ROLL
CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL NINE SO
SIX THE- TO PASS AS A TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTENT. HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES
NOBODY. CENTER BRADFORD. BRED BY
SENATOR JONES. JONES NO. CENTER
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HI. CENTER
LAYERED. LAYER OF ICE CENTER
WACO. CAL ARE. I'VE TO ONE OF
THOSE FIVE S. B. FORTY THREE A
PUBLIC AND RETIREMENT CHARTER
SCHOOLS RECEPTION THE ROLE OF
TWELVE SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE THAT BILL ABOUT FIVE TO
MOVING ON THE SENATE ALONE SB
EIGHT SIXTY ONE DEMENTIA CARE
NAVIGATOR GRANT PROGRAMS HAVE A
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED AT A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET. VERIFY HE PROGRAM
IS A PILOT IN IT CO AUTHORS OR
SUBSTITUTE IN THE ROLE FROM S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO SB EIGHT
SIXTY ONE AS AMENDED IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO S. B. NINE TWELVE
BIOMARKER TESTING IT IS A DEEP
PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. NINE TWELVE
IT IS OUT SEP SEVEN TWO ZERO SB
NINE FIFTY TO EXPANDING AND
LANGUAGE LEARNING SCHOOL GRANT
PROGRAM A ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE
BILL NO FIFTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASSED THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE SENATOR BATES. CENTER
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES I JONES I SENATOR KAMLAGER
. KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED
LAYERED ICE SENATOR WAKO SKI HI
CASKEY VOTERS SIX TO ZERO
DOLLARS OUT SIX ZERO EXT SB NINE
FIFTY EIGHT MEDICATION AND
PATIENT SAFETY ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SUBSIDY THE ROLE OF
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR NINE FIFTY
EIGHT SUBTILIS OUT FIVE TWO TWO
NINE SIX SIX. F. U. H. C. AND
RURAL HEALTH CLINICS IT IS A DO
PASS RECEPTION ROLL FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR NINE SIXTY SIX
THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO SB
TEN FORTY SEVEN EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE TO ROLL CALL VOTE.
SENATE BILL TEN FORTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR WHAT. A SENATOR PORTANTINO
FINE PORTANTINO AYE CENTER
BATES. NOBODY SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES. OF
WHAT SENATOR KAMLAGER. HI
KAMLAGER I SENATOR LAYERED.
LAYERED ICE CENTER WACO SKI HI
THE COSBY BY VOTERS FIVE TWO
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO
ZERO. THAT WAS TEN FORTY SEVEN
CORRECT SB ELEVEN FORTY ONE
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
NONRESIDENT TUITION EXEMPTION.
WERE SUBSIDY IN THE ROW FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR ELEVEN
FORTY ONE SAMPLES OUT FIVE TO SB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO EMPLOYMENT
SALARIES AND WAGES THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED RESENT BUSINESSES
WITH FIFTEEN OR FEWER EMPLOYEES
AND DELAYED PUBLIC DISCLOSURE BY
ONE YEAR. YEAH COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO STRIKE SECTION PERTAINING TO
NOTIFICATION OF INTERNAL JOB
OPENINGS. IT IS A SUBSTITUTE OF
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTEENS ROLE FOR
SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO SO THAT
PHYLLIS OUT FIVE TO TWO SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SIXTY FBI LOAN
RELATED ACTIVITIES DATA ANALYSIS
AND PRACTICES. YEP COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO REVISE THE MORTGAGE
LENDING DATA ANALYSIS AND IT'S A
ROLL CALL VOTE. SAN BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIX THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
AYE SENATOR BATES. BATES KNOWS
CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. JONES CENTER
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES SENATOR
LAYERED LAYERED ICE CENTER
MICHALSKI HI KELSEY I'D ROUTE IS
FIVE TO ONE. OF THOSE OUT FIVE
TWO ONE SB TWELVE THIRTY ON ZERO
IN NEAR ZERO EMISSION INCENTIVES
WE HAVE FOR AUTHORED AN HOUR THE
ELIGIBILITY MAKE OTHER CHANGES
MA'AM INSTEAD CO AUTHORS THE
ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL TWO
THIRTY THE MOTION IS MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. THREE NO. SIR
JONES KNOWS CENTER KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER ICE CENTER LAYERED ON
LAYERED ICE AND A RECORD STREAK
HI CASKEY FIVE OCCURS FIVE TO
ONE THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ONE
S. B. TWELVE NINETY FIVE
HAZARDOUS OR DESERTED WELLS WE
HAVE THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
ENSURE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
CLARIFY GENERAL FUND TO MATCH
CLARIFY GENERAL FUND MATCHING
AND REPORTING WITH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAID CO AUTHORS THIS IS
A SUBSTITUTE OF SB TWELVE
SEVENTEENS FOR TWELVE NINETY
FIVE SO THAT BILL IS OUT. FIVE
TWO TWO S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTMENT
APPOINTMENTS. REPORT IT'S A ROLL
CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL THIRTY
EIGHTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO I'M PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. HI BATES ICE
BRADFORD BRADFORD BY SENATOR
JONES JONES ICE CENTER KAMLAGER
HI KAMLAGER I SENATOR LAYERED
LAYERED ICE WHITE HOUSE GIG HI
BECAUSE. TO SEVEN. THE
PHILADELPHIA ZERO MOVE ON THE
SAN ARMED LEADER SAYS EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR ELECT INFRASTRUCTURE
UNDERGROUNDING PROGRAM IT'S A
SUBSTITUTE OF THE RAW FROM
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR
SUBTILIS OUT FIVE TO TWO. SB
NINE SEVEN EIGHT WILDFIRE DEBRIS
CLEANUP IT'S A SUBSTITUTE TO THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT TO THAT BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO S. B. TENSOR TWO
FIREFIGHTERS. FOR SUBSIDY IN THE
ROLE FROM S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FRESH BE TEN SIXTY TWO BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO S. B. TEN SEVENTY
FOUR CANNABIS EXCISE TAX A
CULTIVATION IT'S A ROLL CALL
VOTE. SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES
. SENATOR BRAD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES NO JONES CENTER
KAMLAGER I AM A EYES LAYERED
LAYERED ICE CENTER WACHOWSKI HI
ACCOUNTS BY LOCUSTS FOR TO ONE.
THAT OUT FIVE TO ONE S. B.
SEVENTY FIVE CAO INTERMODAL
PASSENGER RAIL RECEPTION THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE AND BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO SB ELEVEN NINETY
EIGHT BEER MANUFACTURERS
DIRECTORSHIP INCREMENTS.
RECEPTION IN THE ROLL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT MISTER CHAIR YEAH-
LIVING NINETY EIGHT BACK TO LAY
OUT. YOUR OKAY ROLL CALL ELEVEN
I EIGHT SENATE BILL ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT. MOTIONS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
CENTER. CENTER BY. SENATOR JONES
PUBLIC. CENTER KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER ICE CENTER LAYERED
RIGHT THERE ARE AYE SENATOR
CASKEY HI CASKEY BY LOTUS FORTY
ZERO AND BILLS OUT FORTY ZERO
MOVING ON TO SB TWELVE TWENTY
NINE MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
GRANTS RECEPTION ROLL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TWELVE
TWENTY NINE BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
PROHIBITIVE INVESTMENT CONTRACTS
RUSSIA AND BELARUS ARE MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED AN HOUR THE SCOPE.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TO ME OF
A ROLL CALL WE'RE GONNA DO A
ROLL CALL ON THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO EYES SENATOR BATES
BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES JONES
ICE CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER
EYES CENTER LAYERED ON LAYER I
SENATOR Y. CASKEY NOT VOTING.
BUT IT'S SIX TWO ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT SIX ZERO S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY TWO STILL HAD TROUT FOR
WE HAVE A MEMBERS PER AUTHORED.
THE EXTENSION. THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. SB THIRTEEN
NINETY TWO THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO SB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
FOOD DISTRIBUTION ON INDIAN
RESERVATIONS. TO DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN THIRTEEN TO
THAT PHYLLIS OUT SEVENTY. SEVEN
ZERO S. B. TWELVE FIFTY THREE BY
MELINDA'S. DO PASS AND TO THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
TWELVE FIFTY THREE SO THAT BILLS
OUT SEVENTY ZERO. LIVING ON THE
SENATOR MEN S. B. EIGHT SIXTY
THREE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DEATH
REVIEW TEAMS. SUBSCENE ROLL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR EIGHT
SIXTY THREE SEPARATE WITHOUT
SEVEN ZERO. THREE NINE FIFTEEN
FIREARMS ST PROPERTY. WE'RE
SUBSIDIZING THE RAW FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR NINE FIFTEEN TO
THAT BILL IS OUT. TWELFTH A TO
ME FIVE TO TWO. SB NINE SEVENTY
FIVE COURSE DEBT RIGHT OF ACTION
WE HAVE AMENDMENTS TO DELETE THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION. THAT
BILL IS OUT WITH THE SUBSTITUTE
FROM ROLL CALL FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR NINE SEVENTY FIVE
FIVE TWO TWO. SB ONE THOUSAND
ONE CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER CREDIT
REPORTING RECEPTION THE ROLE
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR.
THOUSAND ONE SO THAT THOSE OUT
SEVEN ZERO S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY
ONE TRANSIT OPERATOR'S
HARASSMENT PLANTS WERE
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO. ELEVEN SIXTY ONE SO
THAT BILLS SEVEN TO ZERO SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR FIREARMS
DEALER. SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. AT BILLS OUT. FIVE
TO. LIVING ON THE SAN NEWMAN
ASKED EIGHTH FIVE TO DRAW DEATH
PILOT PROGRAM. SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE STEP THOSE OUT
SEVENTY ZERO S. B. TEN THIRTY
SIX. WE HAVE A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO CLARIFY COST RECOVERY
REQUIREMENTS MAKE OTHER CHANGES
WE HAVE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
MAKE PROVISIONS CONTINGENT FUND
APPROPRIATION. OR SUBSIDY THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
TEN THIRTY SIX THAT BILLS OUT
SEVEN TO ZERO SB ELEVEN THIRTY
ONE SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM. FOR
SUBSTANTIVE IN THE ROLE FROM SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR SB ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE THAT FILLS OUT FIVE
TWO TWO. SB TWELVE FIFTEEN
BATTERY RECYCLING RECEPTION THE
ROLE FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR
TWELVE FIFTEEN TO THAT BILLS OUT
FIVE TO TWO. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE HYDROGEN FUEL STATIONS
RECEPTION IN THE ROLL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE. AND FLOWS OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO. THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
ALL RIGHT SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN PERSONAL INCOME TAX
CONSUMER PROTECTION VIOLATION
THE MOTION. TO DO PASS AND
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN SO THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE
TO TWO. SB FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AMENDED. TO
MAKE THE BILL CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION AND WE'RE DOING A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTEEN EMOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO HÌNH.
PORTANTINO EYES CENTER BATES.
BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES. SO
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES CENTER
LAYERED. LAYERED ICE AND-
MICHALSKI. CASKEY FIVE SIX TWO
ZERO APPLE IS OUT SIX ZERO
MOVING TO THE CENTER OF CHAU
VOTE MOVING THEM SB ELEVEN
THIRTEEN SPECIAL EDUCATION
INCLUSIVE LEARNING. WE HAVE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO MODIFY THE
BILL'S FUNDING PROVISIONS IN IT
CO AUTHORS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO MAKE THE BILL CONTINGENT ON
APPROPRIATION RECEPTION IN THE
ROLE FROM S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FOR THE MOTION. PASSES AS
AMENDED SEVEN ZERO S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS BETTING PREFERENCES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
RECEPTION IN THE ROLL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE SO THAT BILL PASSES
SEVEN TWO ZERO SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN IS A TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR. IN A TOWN HOMELESS
AND MENTAL HEALTH GRANT PROGRAM
FOR STOCKTON ROLL FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN. SO THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVENTH IS. MOVING TO DOCTOR PAN
SB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT HEALTHCARE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. FOR MOTIONS
CAN PASS RECEPTION IN THE MOST
THE ROLE FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT. SO THAT BILL
PASSES FIVE TO TWO SB NINE A ONE
CITY OF WEST SACRAMENTO FLOOD
PROJECTS IT IS SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO. I DO PASS FOR SB NINE A
ONCE THAT PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO
SB NINE OH SEVEN THE RELIEF
PROGRAM. IT IS A DO PASS A
RECEPTION IN THE ROLL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR NINE OH
SEVEN TO THAT BILL PASSES. SEVEN
ZERO S. B. NINE FOUR FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA AFFORDABLE
ASSISTANCE. IS A DO PASSING OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOUR NINE FOUR
FOUR. THAT BILL PASSES FIVE TWO
TWO SB TEN EIGHTEEN PLATFORM
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
ACT WE HAVE AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS
LEAD TO DISCLOSURE OF ALGORITHMS
AND METRICS. SO THAT WERE
SUBJECT IN THE ROLE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN TO TEN EIGHTY SEVERAL
PASSES FIVE. AMENDED SB TEN
THIRTY THREE HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
YEAH THE MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO
CLARIFY CDI PROVISIONS ARE
CONTINGENT UPON FUNDING. FOR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO WANTED TO PASS
AS AMENDED FOR TEN THIRTY THREE.
SO THAT BILL PASSES. SEVEN TWO
ZERO AS THE TEN NINETY KATEB
ACCOUNT PRODUCTS LABELING AN
ADVERT. WE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THIS. DC'S AND- RESPONSIBLE AND
IT'S A ROLL CALL ON TEN SEVEN.
SO BILL TEN NINETY SEVEN
EMOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO. AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. CENTER BRADFORD.
SENATOR JONES. THANK JONES I
CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER ICE
INTERLAYER LETTERED BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI MAKOWSKI BY
VOTERS FIVE TWO ZERO THAT%
PHYLLIS OUT FIVE ZERO S. B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY RIGHT ACT EXAM PRODUCT
PROSPERING SERVICES WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
412-174-1170 TWO SO THAT BILL TO
DO PASS FIVE. SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
MEDIC CAL TIME AND DISTANCE
STANDARDS TO DO PASS RECEPTIONS
IN THE ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FOR SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SATELLITES OUT SEVEN TO ZERO. SB
TWELVE THIRTY FOUR FAMILY
PLANNING ASPECTS ACCESS CARE AND
TREATMENT. WE HAVE AUTHORS IN
THE MYSTICAL THE ALLOCATION
AMOUNT REQUIRED T. H. C. S.
SUBMIT A REPORT. FOR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN SO AS TO PASS
AS AMENDED FIVE TO TWO. SB
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN CLINICAL
LABORATORY CHEN GENETICS. AND
REPRODUCTIVE BIOLOGIST BIOLOGICS
LICENSES THIS IS A STEP A DO
PASS INTERCEPTED THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN SO THAT BILL PASSED
SEVEN ZERO. SB TWELVE NINETY SIX
VIRAL SURVEILLANCE PROGRAMS TO
DO PASSED WE'RE DOING A ROLL
CALL. SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES
NOBODY SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES I
JONES I SENATOR KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER CENTER LAYER. LAYERED
ICE WAKO SKI. MAKOWSKI WOULD
SIXTIES. THAT BILL OUT SIX ZERO.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO. THIRTY NINE
ON HOSP THAT A MEMBER AT A CO TO
CALL. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE THE MOTION IS PASS A
AMENDED TO SENATE FOR SENATE
REPORT. I YOU KNOW I SAID BATES
. CENTER BRADFORD BRADFORD ICE
JOE. RIGHT JONES ICE CAMPUS HI
STUFF COME I CENTER LAYERED. LET
US UNDER WHY CUSTOM BY TELSEY BY
SIX ZERO THE BILL IS OUT SIX
THIS S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
COVERT NINETY TESTING PLANS FOR
SCHOOLS TO PASS RECEPTION TO THE
MOTION THE ROLL CALL FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN. FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
OF THOSE OUT FIVE TWO TWO SB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ON BIOLOGICS
INVESTIGATIONAL USE SUBSTITUTE
IN THE ROLE FROM SB ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR SB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED THAT BILL IS OUT. SEVEN
ZERO MOVING ONTO SENATOR
PORTANTINO SB EIGHT THIRTY
SCHOOL ENROLLMENT BASED FUNDING
HAVE A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES IN AND A
CO AUTHOR TO ROLL CALL VOTE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO I SENATOR BATES.
SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. EIGHT THIRTY YES. I'M SORRY WHAT- NO SENATOR
JONES NO CENTER KAMLAGER I
KAMLAGER I SAID EARLIER ON LAYER
I SENATOR WHITEHOUSE SKI I ASK
LOTUS TO ONE THE BILL OUT FIVE
ONE S. B. A FIFTY CAL GRANT AND
CITIZENS OF HIGHER EDUCATION WE
HAVE A MEMBERS PER AUTHORED AND
CO AUTHORS RECEPTION IN THE ROLL
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO GREAT
FIFTY ONE THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN
TWO ZERO SB EIGHT SEVENTY
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. TO DO
PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO TO EIGHT
SEVENTY SO THAT BILA OUT SEVENTY
S. NINE OH SIX SCHOOL SAFETY
CASUALTY THREATS WERE
SUBSTITUTED TO PASS RECEPTIONS
IN THE ROLE FROM SB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN NINE OH SIX SO THAT
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO FIFTY
NINE THIRTY TWO CIRCULATION
ELEMENTS BICYCLE PEDESTRIAN AND
TRAFFIC CALMING PLANS OR
SUBSTITUTE IN THE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR NINE THIRTY
TWO THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TO DO
AS A NOTE DO PASSES- SB NINE
FIFTY NINE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA SURPLUS RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY. WITH THE TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL VOTE SENATE BILL NINE
FIFTY NINE EMOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO. AYE
SENATOR BATES. SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD SENATOR JOAN. JONES
KNOWS CENTER. HI KAMLAGER ICE
LAYERS HI LED BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE E. HI MAKOWSKI ARE BOOKS
FIVE TO ONE ABILITY OUT FIVE TO
ONE SB NINE SEVEN FOUR HEALTH
COVERAGE DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING
WORST IS TO DO PASS FOR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FRESHMEN NINE
SEVENTY FOUR SETTLERS OUT SEVEN
TWO ZERO SB NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA CANCER EQUITY ACTED
AS A ROLL CALL VOTE TO PASS.
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES
BATES I CENTER BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE SENATOR JONES JONES KNOWS
CENTER KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
SENATOR LAYERED. HI LARRY I
SENATOR WHEN CASKEY HI MAKOWSKI
ARE THE SIX TO ONE AT BELLSOUTH
SIX ONE S. TEN SIXTEEN SPECIAL
EDUCATION ELIGIBILITY FETAL
ALCOHOL SPECTRUM RECEPTION IS TO
DO PASS RECEPTION IN THE ROLL
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TEN
SIXTEEN TO THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO SB TEN SIXTY SEVEN
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
AUTOMOBILE PARKING REQUIREMENTS
THERE'S AUTHORS AMENDMENT TO
EXPLICITLY EXCLUDE HOTEL AND
MOTEL DEVELOPMENT. IT IS
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVEN TO TEN SIXTY SEVEN
SO THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO Q.
AS AMENDED SB ELEVEN SIXTEEN
PERFORMING ARTS EQUITY PAYROLL
FUND MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED AT A
CO AUTHOR TO ROLL CALL VOTE
SENATE BILL ONE ONE ONE SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES NO CENTER
BRADFORD BRADFORD BY SENATOR
JONES JONES. KNOWS SENATOR
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER AN EARLY.
LAYERED ICE AND- WHAT. COMES
GUITAR BIRDS FIVE TWO. A BILL IS
OUT FOR TO TWO AS A AS EEVENTH
SIX. ENVIRONMENTAL SEQUEL REVIEW
TO DEEP IN A ROW CALL VOTE.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY SIX
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO ALL
RIGHT PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR
BATES HI BATES I CENTER
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES. RIGHT JONES I SENATOR
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER ICE LAYER HI
LAYER OF ICE WAKO HI MY- I LOS
TO ZERO THE BILL HAS OUT SEVEN
ZERO B. TWELVE SEVEN. MY HEALTH
TO DO PASSED WITH A ROLL CALL.
FINNA BILL TWELVE OH SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
TWELVE SEVEN. W. SENT US SENATOR
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES JONES KNOWS KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I SENATOR LAYERED ON
LAYERED I CENTER WHITE HOUSE HI
MAKOWSKI VOTERS FIVE TWO. THAT
WAS OUT FIVE TO S. B. TWELVE
FIFTH FIVE WOULD PROGRAMS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IT'S TO DO PASSED WITH A
ROLL CALL VOTE SENATE BILL
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES
BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES JONES
I CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I
SENATOR LAYERED ON IT LAYERED
ICE AND AWAY CASKEY KELSEY FIVE
SEVEN ZERO OF THOSE OUTS ZERO B.
THIRTEEN OH TWO STUDENT WELLNESS
CENTERS WITH AUTHORS TO MEMBERS
TO ADD INTENT LANGUAGE REGARDING
THE UTILIZATION OF SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES TO DO PASSED IN A ROLL
CALL SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH TO
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO HIGH PORTANTINO AYE
CENTER BATES. YOU KNOW TO.
CORRECT SENATOR BATES ICE CENTER
BRADFORD. BRADFORD FIVE SENATOR
. NO JONES KNOWS SENATOR. I
KAMLAGER ICE INTERLAYER ON LAYER
OF ICE AND WHITEHOUSE HI CUSK
FIVE LOS TO ONE THE BILL IS OUT
SIX TO ONE WITH ON THE JOE ROTH
S. B. A. EIGHT THREE UMBILICAL
CORD BLOOD COLLECTION IS A PASS
AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
SB EIGHT EIGHT THREE SO PASSES
SEVEN ZERO. SB ELEVEN FORTY
THREE IS ACUTE CARE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL LOAN FUNDED AS A TO
PASS A SUBSTANTIVE IN THE ROLL
CALL FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
ELEVEN FORTY THREE APPLE IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO S. B. ELEVEN NINETY
NINE UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE WE HAVE AUTHORS A
MEMBERS THAT A CO AUTHOR.
SUBSTITUTE IN THE MOTION OF THE
MOMENT FOR ME THE ROLL CALL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO TO ELEVEN
NINETY NINE FABULOUS OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO AS AMENDED SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY THREE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TO FOURTEEN THIRTY
THREE SO IT IS A DO PAST SEVEN
TO ZERO SB FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
TO DO PASSED FOR THE BORDER
KILEY CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS
RECEPCI TO THE MOTION FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TO FORTY THIRTY
FOUR SO THAT IS A DO PAST SEVEN
TO ZERO. SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
ON RESPIRATORY CARE BOARD JANET
TO DO PASSOVER SUBSTITUTE IN THE
ROLL FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TO
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX REPTILES OUT
SEVEN ZERO SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD
IT'S A DO PASS AND RECEPTION IN
THE ROLL FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
FOR FOURTEEN THIRTY EIGHT THAT
THOSE OUT SEVEN ZERO SB FOURTEEN
FORTY THREE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS WE HAVE A-
AUTHORS MM INSTEAD CONFORMING
SUNSET DATES. IT IS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED WITH ATTEMPTED TO ROLL
CALL FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO TO
FOURTEEN THAT'S OUT AS SEVEN TO
ZERO SB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS. IT IS
A DO PASS AND RECEPTION IN THE
ROLL CALL FROM ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO. TO FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE
SEPARATE WITHOUT. SEVEN TO ZERO.
NO ON TO SOME RUBIO. EIGHT SIXTY
ON TRIAL TAX. WE HAVE AUTHOR A
MEMBER. WE HAVE A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ME. THEIR MEMBERS
MAKE THE UPON APPROPRIATE. AND
SO THAT IS SUBS WE'RE GOING TO
ROLL CALL IN SB EIGHT SIXTY
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO AYE FORTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY NOT.
SENATOR KAMLAGER ON KAMLAGER I
SENATOR LAYERED- LAYERED ICE
CENTER WHITE HOUSE SKI HI KELSEY
HI LOTUS FIVE ZERO DEVILS OUT
FIVE ZERO S. B. NINE FOURTEEN
HEALTH FACT WE HAVE A MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED AND CO AUTHORS
RECEPTION TO THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOUR NINE
FOURTEEN TO THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN TWO ZERO THREE NINE THIRTY
FOR CHILDHOOD CANCER RESEARCH
GRANT PROGRAM WE HAVE A MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED ALLOW THE GRANT
FUNDING TO BE USED FOR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION AND AT A CO
AUTHOR AND WE HAVE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO MAKE IT CONTINGENT
UPON AN APPROPRIATION.
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO SO THAT BILL
AS AMENDED PASSES SEVEN TWO ZERO
SB TEN EIGHTY ONE UNLAWFUL
DISTRIBUTION OF INTIMATE IMAGES
WE HAVE A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR TEN EIGHTY
ONE SO AS AMENDED THAT BILL
PASSES TO THE SENATE FOR SB
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VISITATION YEAH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR CLARIFYING
CHANGES WERE SUFFERED THE ROLE
FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE FOR THE BILL
AS AMENDED MOVES TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN.
BUBBLE HOME PARK LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO LIMIT ATVS
TRANSLATION REQUIREMENTS
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE OF ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR THIRTEEN OH SEVEN
SO THAT BILL AS AMENDED MOVES TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE LCF BASE GRANTED
JUDGMENT THEM IS TO MAKE THE
BILL CONTINGENT ON AN
AFFILIATION FOR THE MOTION IS TO
MOVE AS AMENDED AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TO FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE SO AS AMENDED THAT MOVIE
BILL MOVES TO THE SENATE FOR
SEVEN TO ZERO. SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN SCHOOL TEACHER EXIT
SURVEYS MOTIONS TO PASS
RECEPTIONS IN THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN SEXUAL PASSES SEVEN TWO
ZERO SENATOR SKINNER S. B. EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES. TO DO
PASSING A ROLL CALL VOTE. SAN
BILL EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT THEM. DO
TO THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR PER.
I FOURTEEN I SAID BATES. SENATOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES JONES NO CENTER KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER ICE AND- LAYERED
LAYERED ICE SENATOR WAKO SKI HI
CASKEY I WAS FIVE TO ONE THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ONE SB NINE
OH FIVE DECARBONISATION CEMENT
CARBON SEQUESTRATION WE HAVE A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
RESEARCH- PERMISSIVE EXTEND
TIMELINE TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES WERE SUBSTITUTED THE
ROLE FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR
NINE OH FIVE SO THE BILL AS
AMENDED MOVES TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. NINE NINE THREE VICTIMS
AND PERSONS ARONIE ASLI
CONVICTED WE HAVE AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHOR TO STRIKE THE REQUIREMENT
TO INCLUDE A SPECIFIED STATEMENT
INFORMATION MATERIALS AND AT A
CO AUTHOR SO THE MOTION IS TO
MOVE TO THE CENTER FOR AS
AMENDED PERCEPTION THE ROLE FROM
TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR NINE NINE
THREE STEP BILL MOVES. AS
AMENDED FIVE TO TWO SB TEN TEN
STATE VEHICLE FLEET DEB'S MEN'S
PER AUTHORED A STRIKE CARVER
CARMEN REQUIRED TGS TO INCREASE
THE USAGE OF STATE STEPS TO
OVERTIME AND IT'S A ROLL CALL
VOTE SENATE BILL TEN TEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES NO SENATOR
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES NO JONES KNOWS CENTER
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I CENTER
LAYERED LAYERED ICE SENATOR WAKO
SKI BY ASKI I'D FIVE TO TWO THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO SB TEN
SEVENTY FIVE CLEAN HYDROGEN HAVE
FUN IN THE CARBONIZATION
STRATEGIES IT'S MOTIONS DO
PASSES AMENDED PER AUTHOR TO ADD
GRANT PRIORITIZATION CRITERIA
MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING AND
PRAGMATIC CHANGES. SO WE'RE
SUBJECT TO THE ROLE FROM ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR TEN SEVENTY FIVE
SO IT PASSES THE SENATE FOR AS
AMENDED SB TEN EIGHTY THREE CAL
WORKS PREGNANCY IN HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE IT IS A TO PASS
SUBSTITUTE IN THE ROLE FROM S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO SB EIGHTY
THREE SO THAT BILL PASSES TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. SEVEN TO ZERO
THREE ONE ONE ONE FIVE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS WOMAN IN CONSTRUCTION
PRIORITY. IS A ROLL CALL VOTE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO ALL
RIGHT TO KNOW I. SENATOR BATES.
SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN. WITH ELEVEN
YES MA'AM I KNOW. BATES NO
SENATOR PER BREF AYE SENATOR
JONES JONES KNOWS CAMPUS.
KAMLAGER I SENATOR LAYERED ALL
RIGHT LET I CENTER STREET HI
MICHAEL SCHIAVO SUPPOSE. FIVE TO
TWO. ALL RIGHT BILL WROTE THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO. THAT
WAS OUR THERE WAS TEN EIGHTY OR
ONE WAS A THAT WAS ONE ONE MORE
FIVE CORRECT ARMENPRESS RELATION
WOMAN. PARTY SO THAT IS OUT SB
TWELVE OH SIX HYDRO FLUOROCARBON
GASES THAT WE HAVE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO EXTEND THE TIME
LINE AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES. SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED OR SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN
FOR TWELVE OH SIX ANNAPOLIS OUT
FIVE TWO TWO MOVING TO SENATOR
STERN. WE HAVE S. B. L. SIXTY
FOUR BILL ENERGY EFFICIENT READ.
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE
ELEVEN SIXTY FOR THE MOST IS TO
PAY TO THIS FLOOR SENATE
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. HI BATES AYE
SENATOR BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. JONES I CENTER
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I SENATOR
LAYERED ARE LAYERED BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI KELSEY I.
SEVEN ZERO. AT IS OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO. WILL MOVE ON SB TWELVE SIX
INCOME TAX GROSS INCOME
EXCLUSION WILDFIRES DO PASS
RECEPTIONS IN THE ROLE FROM SB
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR SB TWELVE
FORTY SIX SO THAT BILL PASSES.
TO THE SENATE FOR SEVEN TWO ZERO
SB TWELVE SIXTY ONE RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING HEAT MITIGATION GRANTS
HAVE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
IT CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE SENATE
BILL TWELVE SIXTY ONE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATE
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES DURING
CENTER BRADFORD. REDFORD ICE
CENTER JONES JONES NO CENTER
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES LAYERED
FLARED BY SENATOR WHAT KASKY HI
CASKEY BY VOTERS FIVE TO ONE OF
THOSE OUT FIVE ONE S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX MENTAL HEALTH
CARE GUARANTEED RIGHTS. IT IS A
DO PASS AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM. TWELVE SEVENTEEN
FOR FOURTEEN FORTY SIX THAT
BILLS OUT FIVE TO TWO SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX IT SAID DO
HARRIS SAID IT'S PROPERTY
TAXATION WELFARE EXEMPTION LOW
INCOME HOUSING SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY SIX FOR
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX VESSELS OUT
SEVEN TO ZERO SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO HEY KILLER
MANSLAUGHTER BY GROSS NEGLIGENCE
WE HAVE. MANY MEMBERS TO DELETE
PRIOR CONVICTIONS FROM THE
DEFINITION OF GROSS NEGLIGENCE
THAT BILL WILL BE OUT AS AMENDED
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX SET UP IT WILL BE OUT SEVEN.
OH NO THAT'S A ROLL CALL EXCUSE
ME THAT'S YOUR FOURTEEN SEVENTY
TWO ZERO I'M SORRY FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO IS A ROLL CALL SEVEN
ZERO. AND SO FORTH SEVENTY TWO
OUT AS AMENDED. A SEVENTY ZERO
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX AT LEAST SO CANYON
NATURAL GAS STORAGE FACILITY. WE
HAVE A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
MAKE LADWP REQUIREMENT
PERMISSIVE. IF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO REQUIRE CPUC TO CONSIDER
MINIMIZING OR CLOSING THE
FACILITY LIEU OF CLOSING IN
AMONG OTHER THINGS. IT IS A ROLL
CALL VOTE SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
AYE SENATOR BATES. NOBODY
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR JONES
NETWORK. SENATOR KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I SENATOR LAYERED
LAYERED BY SENATOR CASKEY NOT
VOTING. OKAY WE HAVE THREE VOTES
WE HAVE THREE RESTAURANTS PUT
THAT ON CALL. YOU GUYS SHOULD
TAKE A TRIP TO SET LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS AND YEAH A CHANCE TO
SEE THEM GO. ALL RIGHT SENATOR
SENATE SENATOR- BIRDS SB EIGHT
THREE SEVEN DRIVER'S LICENSE
BETTERTON DESIGNATION WE HAVE A
TO PASS AND IT'S A SUBSTITUTE SB. SAYS TO THE FLOOR SEVENTY TWO
SB NINE EIGHTY SIX CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS WE HAVE A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO SPECIFY ADDITIONAL
EXEMPTIONS AND AMEND TO ADD A CO
AUTHOR- SO WE ARE PASSING THAT
SET THE ROLE OF ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FOR NINE EIGHTY SIX AND IT
IS PASSES SEVEN ZERO AS AMENDED.
SB TEN FIFTY SIX VIOLENT POSTS
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE
BILL TEN FIFTY SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO BY
SENATOR BATES. CENTER BRADFORD
FOR BY SENATOR JONES JONES KNOWS
CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES
CENTER LAYERED LAYER TYSON-
WHITE COUNTY HI MAKOWSKI BY
VOTERS FIVE TO ONE THAT FILLS
OUT FIVE TO ONE SB TEN SIXTY
NINE STATE GRANT PROGRAM
NEGOTIATED COST AGREEMENTS WERE
SUBJECT TO THE ROLE OF ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO FOR TEN SIXTY NINE
AND IT IS A DO PASS SO GOES THE
FOUR SEVEN TWO ZERO S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY SOCIAL SERVICES.
ELECTRONIC BENEFITS TO DO PAST
SUMMER SUBS THE ROLE OF ELEVEN
TWENTY TO ELEVEN FORTY SO THAT
PASSES TO THE SENATE FLOOR SEVEN
TWO ZERO SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
ANAHEIM TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
S. T. A. PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE SENATE
BILL ALEF SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO. I AYE SENATOR BATES
ABILITY. CENTER BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES JONES
I CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES
SENATOR LAYERED LAYERED ICE
CENTER WORKOUTS SKI HI MY COUNTY
BY VOTERS. SIX TWO ZERO. I'M
SORRY WHERE WERE WE VOTED SIX TO
ZERO ON SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX SO
THAT IS OUT SIX TO ZERO SB
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT UC HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF LAW IT IS A TO PASS
RECEPTION TO THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO TO TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT SO THAT BILL
PASSES. SEVEN TWO ZERO S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT CARE COURT
PROGRAM WE HAVE A MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO MODIFY CARE COURT
PROCEEDING SPECIFY THAT CARE
GREEN WHICH ARE COVERED BY
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS ALLOW
LOCAL ENTITIES TO BE PARTIES TO
CARE. PROCEEDINGS AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES AS AMENDED WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR A LOT
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT SO THAT
GOES TO THE FLOOR AS AMENDED
SEVEN ZERO S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
ELECTIONS DISCLOSURE
CONTRIBUTIONS. IT'S A DO PASS
RECEPTION ROLE 412-172-1360 THAT
BILL PASSES FIVE TWO MOVING TO
CENTER WHITE COW SKI S. B. EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN ON EIGHTY U. G.
JUNIOR EIGHTY USE AMENDMENTS TO
DELETE THE CHANGED OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE A
SUBSTITUTE BROKE OFF A TWELVE
SEVENTEEN. EIGHT NINETY SEVEN
THAT BILL PASSES FIVE TO TWO AS
AMENDED SB TEN TWENTY SIX
RESIDENTIAL ENERGY EFFICIENCY
DISCLOSURE THE TO PASS RECEPTION
TO THAN THE MOBILE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN FOR TEN TWENTY SIX
THAT BILL PASSES FIVE TO. BE.
TEN NINETY NINE BANKRUPTCY
DEBTORS. MENTAL FOR AUTHORED
STRIKING PER SE INTEREST CAPS.
AND SO THAT. THE BILL WERE
SUBZERO FROM TWELVE SEVENTY TO
TEN NINETY NINE CENTS BILL
PASSES AS AMENDED FIVE TO TWO.
SB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE CARBON
CAPTURE DEMONSTRATION PROJECT
GRANTS WE HAVE A MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED AT WORK FORCE
REQUIREMENTS EXPAND THE PROGRAM
TO YOU L'UTILISATION RECEPTION
IN THE ROLE FROM TWELVE
SEVENTEEN. TO THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE AT BILL PASSES FIVE TO TWO
SENATOR WIENER SB EIGHT THIRTY
FOR TAX EXEMPT STATUS
INSURRECTION- WORST TO DO PASS
RECEPTION IN THE ROLE FROM SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN SB EIGHT THIRTY
FOUR. SOUTH BILL PASSES BY TO
ACHIEVE. ALL RIGHT I'M IN WILL
HOLD ON ONE SECOND WHEN I GO
BACK AND LIFT THE CALL. ON WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL IN SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX AT LEAST SO
CANYON NATURAL GAS STORAGE
FACILITY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE FLOOR WE HAVE THE
CHAIR VOTING ARE THE BY SURE NOT
LOADING. SENATOR BATES. NO
VOTING SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR JONES.
SENATOR Y. CASKEY. WE HAVE OVER
FORTY ZERO FABULOUS OUT FORTY
ZERO WE LEFT OFF ON EIGHT FIFTY
THREE CORRECT. YES CORRECT SB
EIGHT FIFTY THREE PRESCRIPTION
DRUG COVERAGE IT IS A DEEP PASS
AND WE'RE GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLE FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO FOR
EIGHT FIFTY THREE THAT BILL
PASSES SEVEN ZERO SB EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT HEALTH PLAN CIVIL
PENALTIES. WE HAVE A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO CLARIFY TO FIND
AMOUNTS TO BE ADJUSTED ANNUALLY
IN RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN SB EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT SEVERAL PASSES FIVE TO SB
EIGHT SEVEN NINE TALK TO COLIN
TRICKLE TESTING ON DOGS AND
CATS. YOU HAVE A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO CLARIFY THAT THE
MEDICAL RESEARCH IS EXEMPT FROM
THE PROHIBITION OR SUBSTITUTE IN
THE HALL FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
SO AS AMENDED THAT BILL PASSES
SEVEN TWO ZERO SB EIGHT EIGHT
SEQUEL EXEMPTION. HAVE AUTHORS
MEMBERS TO CLARIFY PROJECT
REQUIREMENTS AND IT CO AUTHORS
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE SENATE
BILL EIGHTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES. NOT
VOTING. CENTER BRADFORD. SENATOR
JONES. JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER ICE CENTER LAYERED.
LAYERED ICE CENTER MICHALSKI.
MICHALSKI FIVE WE HAVE FIVE
VOTES THE BILL IS FIVE RIGHT NOW
SB THAT BILLS OUT EXTENDED THE
SOMETIME LIKE TWENTY MINUTES ONE
.COM. YEP THAT BILL OUT FIVE TWO
ZERO. SB NINE TWENTY THREE ON
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE IT IS- DO
PASSOVER SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN FOR NINE
TWENTY THREE SEP BILL PASSES
FIVE TWO. SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
REVITALIZATION ACT WE HAVE
AUTHORS MEMBERS RECOUP REMOVED
PROVISIONS RELATED TO GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS A TWO
PASSES AMENDED RECEPTION ROLE
FROM TWELVE SEVENTEEN TO NINE
SIXTY FOUR SO THAT BILL PASSES
SEVEN TO ZERO FIVE SB ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR- WATER EFFICIENCY AND
QUALITY ASSESSMENT REPORT STATE
BUILDING PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE A
MEMBERS PROFIT RESULT REVISED
CPAS PACIFY TESTING REQUIREMENTS
LEAD TESTING STANDARDS QUALIFIED
PERSONNEL IN COMPLIANCE TIMELINE
TO ROLL CALL VOTE. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FORTY FOR THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES. ELEVEN FORTY FOUR.
BETEILIGT BATES BY CENTER
BRADFORD SENATOR JONES JONES NO
CENTER KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER ICE
AND- LAYERED LAYERED ICE CENTER
Y. CASKEY CASKEY FIVE LIVE FIVE
TO ONE LOOK AT THOSE OUT FIVE TO
ONE MOVING ON THE SENATE BILL
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE DNA SAMPLES TO DO
PASSED WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FROM SB ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO FOR SB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
ON CRIMINAL PROCEDURE DNA. SO
THAT BILL MOVES TO THE FLOOR
SEVEN ZERO S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
SIX INCOME TAX CREDITS CANNABIS
BUSINESS WE HAVE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHORED AN HOUR THE ELIGIBILITY
TO ROLL CALL VOTE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE.
FORTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
SENATOR BRADFORD SENATOR JONES
JONES AISIN- KAMLAGER. I SENT A
KAMLAGER I CENTER LAYERED
LAYERED ICE CENTER MICHALSKI HI
KELSEY ARE IS FIVE TWO ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO. YOUR LAST
AUTHOR US SENATE LEADER WILK SB
NINE FORTY SEVEN WHISTLEBLOWER
STATE CONTRACTS IT IS A DO PASS
WERE SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION
FROM LEFT OR THE ROLL CALL FROM
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO TO NINE FORTY
SEVEN SETTLERS OUT OF. SEVEN TO
ZERO S. B. TEN EIGHTY NINE MEDIC
CAL I CLASS PRISON INDUSTRIAL.
RT IT IS A SUBSTITUTE OF THE
ROLL CALL FROM ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
TO TEN NINETY NINE A TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR STEP WAS OUT.
SEVEN TWO ZERO OUR LAST BILL IS
SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE NO BID
CONTRACTS EXTENSION OR RENEWAL
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. COMMITTEE
AMENDS TO NCREASE THE THRESHOLD
FOR CONTRACTS REQUIRING
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. AND SO
THAT BILL MOVES TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATE SEVEN TWO ZERO. I
EVERYTHING. RIGHT MARKET WE'RE
FINISHED WE'RE A FINISHED THANK
YOU EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE
THERE IS NO TESTIMONY WE GOT
THROUGH A LOT OF BILLS. AGAIN
THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE. CROSS
THEN THE NEXT DAY OR TWO THE
ANALYSIS WILL BE POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE WHEN. TODAY THE THAT THE
ANALYSIS FOR ANY AMENDMENTS WILL
GO UP TODAY SO GO TO OUR
WEBSITE. AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AND THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.